HELLO EVERYBODY!
HELLO HELLO!
Sorry, I wasn't finished singing!
I mean, no, no, no!
Did you guys enjoy your, like, eighth loop of that song?
We were live this entire time!
We were looping, guys!
Right?
Yeah!
Yeah, we were looping!
For eight times in a row!
Wait...
What's wrong with my audio?
Am I better?
What's wrong?
I'm so sorry!
Hello?
Is it better?
Hello, is it better?
Oh, okay.
Oh, thank god.
I'm so sorry.
What was it?
What happened?
I was like, no!
No!
Okay, so what happened was that...
Um...
I had to restart my GoXLR.
And what happened was that...
Uh...
No, what happened was that...
Was that I was eating...
I ordered Jollibee's for dinner.
Sorry, dinner time.
And obviously, dad is very food motivated.
So he went into my room.
Because he was like, can I have some chicken?
And I was like, no, you're allergic.
And he's like, I don't want chicken!
And then he, like, bumped into...
He, like, bumped into...
Um...
The...
The power cable for the GoXLR.
So the GoXLR reset itself.
Because it was like...
It was like, what the fuck?
And then he bumped into it.
So the GoXLR reset itself.
But I didn't realize...
I thought it would be fine.
Because it was still on.
So...
Because I thought it was...
I thought it would be fine.
Because my GoXLR was still on.
But I didn't realize it, like...
It, like, fucked it up.
So...
But it's okay.
It's fine now.
I freaked out.
I was like, what are you guys talking about?
What do you mean?
There's something wrong.
Also, what is my BGM?
Let's see.
Alright, free.
I have no idea what BGM this is, so...
Oh, this works.
This BGM works.
We're gonna listen to that.
Alright, anyway, so...
It has been...
Almost...
How many months has it been?
Since I announced the contest.
The waifu cup contest.
It's been a lot of months.
Maybe 5 plus months.
We...
We received...
700 plus!
By the way, I don't know the exact number.
But it was...
700 plus...
Entries.
So, it was a lot of work.
My assistant...
Actually...
Helped me out with...
Going through the first pass.
So, my assistant...
Helped me...
Narrow it down...
To a hundred...
And sixteen...
Files.
Art files to look through to.
Because, obviously...
Like, it was a lot.
So, my assistant looked through the criteria.
So, there was a criteria.
We had to look through the right file.
The right format.
The right logo and everything.
So, from 700 plus...
To a hundred...
And sixteen entries.
And from there...
I took over...
And narrowed it down...
To...
Thirty-five...
Thirty-four entries.
Within those thirty-four...
We selected twenty-two...
To win the eight-thousand dollar prize money.
So, it's not like...
They're all gonna get eight-thousand dollars.
By the way, the prize pool for this...
Is eight-thousand dollars.
American.
So, that eight-thousand dollars...
Is divided amongst...
Twenty-two participants.
I think it's twenty-two.
Twenty...
It's a lot.
Let me make sure I'm saying the right things.
Because...
It took a long time.
One of the reasons...
Why this took...
Forever...
Was that...
Obviously, narrowing it down...
Was very difficult.
Narrowing it down all the entries...
Was incredibly difficult.
And also...
Behind the scenes...
A lot of stuff was...
A lot of stuff came up behind the scenes.
So, basically...
Something would come up...
That I couldn't finish judging.
So, things kept coming up behind the scenes.
But eventually...
We were able to do it.
I was able to sit down...
For...
I think it took me...
One to two weeks.
Overall...
Overall, it took me two weeks of judging...
To finally get to...
Not like in two weeks...
It was like overall...
If we added all the time I spent...
When I had time to judge...
It took two weeks to narrow it down...
To...
To like 35...
What was it?
35?
34.
So, I narrowed it down to 34.
But only 22 entries...
Are going to get prize money.
So, for those who don't know...
Um...
First place...
We end up picking...
Two artworks...
For first place.
Because it was so difficult.
So, in the beginning...
It was three second places...
Um, but in the end...
I decided...
Well, it was me.
I was the final pick.
I was the final judge.
So, all the artworks... I was the final judge.
Um, I picked...
Two artwork pieces...
To be the...
To be first place.
And those two art pieces...
Will be on one cup.
One waifu cup.
So, the front side and the back side...
Will have two different illustrations.
Because it was very difficult.
It was really hard to choose between the two.
So, first place...
Not only do they get the waifu cup...
Uh...
Being on the waifu cup...
They also get $2500 each.
So...
First...
The two first place placements...
Will get $2500 each person.
Um, second place...
Gets $1000.
Uh, third place... $500.
Fourth to fifth place...
$250.
And sixth to 22nd...
Oh, sorry.
Sixth to 20th...
Will get $100.
So, um...
The first to fifth place winners...
We've contacted all the artists...
That got placed in first to fifth...
And I think we contacted...
I don't know if we contacted the artists for sixth to 20th...
But for the first to fifth...
Um...
Not only...
Would...
The two first place winners...
Get to be on the waifu cup...
They will also...
Individually...
Will be on t-shirts.
So you can buy...
The designs on a t-shirt.
And not all...
And then I think...
I'm not sure if it's gonna change...
But the reason why we contacted first to fifth...
Is that...
If you buy the bundle...
I think it's the bundle...
You'll get a gacha for stickers...
That will include the first to fifth...
Prize winners.
So, you could have like a sticker...
That was based off the design...
Of first to fifth.
It's like...
I think it's gacha...
Regarding which one you'll get...
I'm not sure to finalize the details yet...
But I'll let you guys...
I'll explain more later...
The t-shirts are not gacha...
It's the stickers...
So first and fifth will be...
Available to purchase later on...
Anyway...
I need you guys to know...
It was so difficult...
It was incredibly difficult...
I would like to thank my assistant...
For making this form...
For making this powerpoint...
To help me with judging...
So what I will be showcasing you guys...
Right now...
Will be like...
Not all of them...
Because there's 700 plus entries...
But...
I'll be going through...
The final round...
Where I looked through the entries...
So it's like a hundred of them...
Hahahaha...
Like I said...
I'd like to thank my assistant...
For making this...
It was a lot easier to look through...
So as you see...
It says who the artists are...
What it looks like in different colors...
So the first one obviously...
There's Knight OwO...
By the way...
My criteria...
Of picking...
I...
In terms of like...
I looked at...
Where I believe...
Fits my personality the most...
Because there was some artwork...
That was really really good...
But they didn't place higher...
Because I felt like...
Oh I wanted it to fit like...
My personality more...
So like I didn't place it as high...
Like someone might be like...
Oh wait but this one looks really well drawn...
But then for like certain...
For like products...
I wanted it to fit my personality more...
So it took like... I was looking into that...
As well as the effort that was put into it...
Like how...
Like the effort and everything...
So it was so difficult guys...
It was...
It was so difficult...
This one's by...
Oh my gosh I love the...
I love like the...
The details on the dress itself...
Like the ruffles and everything...
And they include all the dragons and the tomato...
I love how like...
Everybody included...
Like elements of different...
Elements of me...
By the way it's gonna be retro doki...
For the main cup...
The waifu cup...
It will be retro doki...
But maybe in the future...
I have been talking to gamersubs about...
Another product in the future...
With current doki...
So there's that...
This one's 7M digital...
Oh my gosh this is gonna take a while...
But it all looks...
It's so difficult...
Oh my gosh... Like it all looks...
So good...
Like I love the dynamics...
Of everything...
And included the tomato...
And the background too...
Like I was like thinking about like...
Will it look good on a cup...
You know like I wanted to make sure...
The details and everything...
Was uh...
Legible you know legible...
Um so that people can see...
Exactly what it looks like...
Cause it's like it's not printed tiny...
But it was more so like you know...
I wanted to make sure that things can be seen...
This one's by 99raisins...
Uh please check out all these...
Artists out...
Like I said like...
I don't know how long it's gonna take...
Oh my god I'm scrolling...
This is...
I also like some artists...
Have made like their own background...
Like it's not just a regular rectangle...
They actually like...
Went out of their way to make like a custom...
Background shape and everything...
Um so like you know...
It's not just a rectangle and stuff...
And then there's like the dragons and everything...
There's this one...
I'm underneath the water...
I'm pressed up...
You can see the...
This is by...
Oh there's also...
So like I said...
Some artists submitted multiple drawings...
Um it was actually crazy cause like...
There are artists that submitted multiple...
That uh got...
It was so difficult...
But they could only have one artwork...
That won...
And because they could only have one artwork that won...
Um actually liked both of their pieces...
Um...
So like there are some...
Lots of artists that submitted more than one entry...
And I know there was like two artists...
That accidentally gave them...
More than one prize placements...
Because I wasn't paying attention to the username...
I was looking at the artwork...
And then I had to pick one...
And then uh move somebody from the honorable mentions...
Up to...
Um...
Up to the top...
So I had to like move people around...
Um just cause it was so difficult...
Like some people submitted lots of really good...
Uh really good artwork...
For like...
And I wanted to pick both...
But I can't cause I want to give everybody a chance...
I really wanted to give everybody a chance to...
Uh...
Like get a prize money basically...
Um there's Akusawa...
I love the shoujo style of this...
And...
And like you guys picked...
There was you know...
I gave you guys any choices for outfits too...
So you guys like...
There was like a variety of outfits...
I also tried to make sure...
I picked like different elf...
Like I wanted it not to be the same outfit...
So I tried to make sure like...
It's different outfits and everything...
Uh...
In the final...
Like the top 22...
Uh...
Day jam thank you for the super chat thank you thank you...
Second alert blocking the art occasionally...
Oh okay...
Let me move it real fast...
Sorry I didn't notice that...
Uh where do I put this alert...
Where do I put you...
Oh wait I have two alerts...
Oops...
I didn't even realize I had...
Professional...
I didn't even realize I had two alerts on...
Whoops...
Hahaha...
I was...
I'm such a mess lately...
Hahaha...
It's the charm...
It's the fucking charm...
This one is by...
Alley cats...
Hmm...
My assistant even like put in their like...
Social media and everything...
Which is...
They did so much this...
They did so much but...
Like I like how this pops out of the box...
Um please support these artists...
If you want to commission them yourself...
Or like you know check them out...
Please check them out here...
Their names are right here...
Um...
Oh my gosh...
Another one by alley cats...
A lot of ultoki there...
I love...
Oh my gosh I just love the composition of this...
And there's like the sleepy dragon here too...
Oh you guys can't see it no...
Hahaha...
You guys can't see the bottom...
There should be a dragoon down there...
At the bottom left...
Um this one is also by alley cats...
Guys we're at 10 out of 115...
Guys...
We're here for the long run...
Hahaha...
Until we get to the final...
This one is...
Um...
I do like the inclusion of text too...
Um because like...
You know they don't have a lot of color...
Oh my god I didn't notice this but there's tiny dragoons here...
Uh but...
Um...
I like the way...
People like try to creatively...
Sneak in the gamersubs logo...
Um there were some people...
That did submit their artwork...
Where the gamersubs logo had to be drawn...
It can't be like copy and pasted randomly...
So...
We had to like...
I remember my assistant told me that...
That was one of the things...
That had to be filtered out...
Because like we had like guidelines...
About regarding um...
Like uh...
Acceptable pieces...
And it's just...
It's just interesting to see where people like...
Place the gamersubs logo...
And like have it drawn as well...
Like how they drew it too...
So it's interesting to see...
Um this one is also by Annie019...
Um this one...
They have like a...
Poker card theme...
And then there's the name...
My name here...
And the gamersubs...
Oh that's so creative...
Wait I didn't notice that...
The gamersubs logo is where like my pins are too...
On the hat...
And then there's like the little drag...
There's a tomato right here...
But you guys don't see it...
But he's like right here...
Um but there's the gamersubs logo too...
This one's also by Annie019...
Yes these numbers were like...
The submission number...
Of what number they were when they submitted...
So like I said...
It was a lot...
There's...
Ashix...
Um...
Oh I love the line art...
I love like the screen tones they use too...
Like a lot of the artists use like different types of screen tones...
Since they only have like...
Black and white...
Uh they only have like the usage of black and white...
And then...
This obviously has to be like transparent...
Like it's not fully...
It doesn't have to be yellow...
This is...
The yellow part is where the liquids are...
So um...
This is where like the...
I guess the gamersub...
Gamersub liquids was gonna be...
So it's really creative to see how they did it...
So it has to be transparent for...
It to pass through...
So the fact that they made the hair...
And the trophy yellow is very...
Like transparent is very creative...
So then it would be red hair...
Green hair...
And blue hair...
They had to keep out cross lines...
And...
Oh the dragoons would be yellow...
And then the little buttons too...
The little buttons would have been yellow...
Or transparent...
I love how people are creative with how...
They put the transparency...
Just like where they place it and everything...
And then...
This reminds me...
This art style reminds me of...
Gorilla's art style...
There's Orochima...
Um... I love the...
I just think it reminds me of Gorilla's...
Yeah it's so cool...
There's so many different art styles too...
I also made sure to pick different art styles...
For...
Top 22...
And the honorable mentions...
Just because like...
I wanted to show a diverse range of styles...
To get...
For the prize money as well...
Um... and...
I just wanted some more diversity and stuff when it comes to like...
Whoever gets to the top 22...
So...
Oh my god...
See...
You guys can tell why it's so difficult...
This one is also by Orochima...
Um...
And it's a different style...
Oh I love like...
It's just so dynamic in general...
Like the pose...
Like the top bottom and everything...
And the little dragon over there...
You don't see much but he's over here...
And then...
Black Buriti...
With the little star here...
He has so many...
There are so many talented artists...
Um... I wish I could make all of them into merch but...
Um...
Unfortunately...
We can't...
I really like this one for the fact that the background...
Was incredibly creative...
Cause like... you know...
A lot of people could just go with the rectangular box...
But they went beyond that...
And went with the...
Cause like normally...
The waifu cups are just like a rectangular box...
But I love how creative people...
Have been with like...
Going beyond that and like making it...
You know like putting a star at the bottom...
And then making the box put like stars around...
With the screen tones and everything...
And I love the expression...
The expression was really good as well...
Uh... this one by...
J.O.
OSHA from... on Instagram...
They do have a Twitter right here...
Uh...
But it's like different...
But we have the Lunar New Year Doki!
Um...
I think every outfit...
Almost every outfit...
Is represented in...
Uh...
In the final selection...
Because like I said...
I wanted every outfit to be represented...
So...
Oh my god is that an egg?
Is that him?
Is that him as a dragon?
Why does he have hair?
Why does he...
That's so cute!
He has hair over there!
Hahaha...
Anyway...
And there's the...
Oh I like how the dragon print...
Is also transparent too...
Uh...
This is Boreal Yakko...
I really like this one...
Hahaha...
I just thought it was so...
It was just so creative...
Hahaha...
I remember seeing this...
On Twitter...
And I was like...
Wait that's so cute...
Like the...
The dragoon racing...
With the long goon...
I thought that was...
I thought that one was like...
Just super clever...
Hahaha...
Yeah like the long...
The long dragoon...
Like it predicted...
It predicted my outfit debut...
My new skin suit debut...
You know with the wallpaper...
With the long drag...
Riding the long dragoon...
Hahaha...
I remember when I saw this on Twitter...
And I was like...
Oh my god that's actually so cute...
Um...
And I really like the...
Uh...
By the way...
No guys by the way...
The winners are also in this powerpoint...
By the way...
That reveals who the winners are...
So like all the ones you see here...
The winners are in this powerpoint...
It's just...
We don't know which one is the winner...
Hahaha...
We just don't know which one is which...
This is basically...
The top 115...
Hahaha...
Um...
Burnt green tea...
The low made outfit...
The outfit design was...
Adorable...
Regarding turning my thief outfit...
Into a...
The thief outfit...
Into a regular maid outfit...
It's basically almost the same thing...
It's just they changed...
A couple little things...
That makes it into a maid outfit...
Um...
There's like...
I like the hat too...
I'm here to take your order...
And then all the dragoons over there...
And like...
I'm gonna serve...
The dragoons up to be consumed...
Hahaha...
I don't know why you guys are so happy...
I'm gonna be giving you...
To be eaten...
Hahaha...
We are literally on a silver platter...
Guys...
This one is by Chip Oily...
Um...
And also in the Lunar New Year outfit...
The clouds in the background like this...
That's so cute...
Hahaha...
That's so creative...
With the clouds and stuff intersecting with the background...
Um...
And then a little dragoon...
I'm giving you guys a little hug...
Is that cute?
Alright...
Um...
I really like the fact that...
Oh the hair is done really well...
The hair...
The eyeliner...
And then there's a little dragoon in the background...
Wait I didn't see that...
There's a little dragoon silhouette...
So clever...
And then like the trophy...
The oshi mark...
Uh...
And then...
The little silhouette...
It's so clever like this...
And then the tomato...
I love how a lot of people added the tomato...
Oh my god that game is so cool...
It's like oh wait you guys can see it...
Hahaha... it got cut off.
But then there's the crown, too.
Alright, there's a clear art.
I like how this one's not straight in terms of the other ones.
It's a little slanted.
It's a little slanted there.
So it is a lot different.
And the way they like...
Oh my god, the GamerSub logo!
It's not the star!
It's the GamerSub logo!
Oh, it's so creative!
Like I said, where people put the GamerSub logo, I just love the creativity the artists have when it comes to where they placed it.
And the fact that it's where the star is, too.
And you guys are here between the thighs and the screen tone for shading and everything, too.
And there's another one by Clear Art.
So the one with hugging the dragoons.
Dragon plushies.
And then the clip is the GamerSub logo.
And then all the different forms of the dragoons, too.
Chonky, long goon, egg, and regular goon.
And then this one by Crispy Chip.
We have...
As I said, I love how Tomato's just there.
My real form is just there.
And I love the creative background they have here.
And everything.
And...
Oh, wait!
The little...
Like, the white shading.
That's so...
Wait, that's so smart.
Like, they added additional shading into the transparency to give it dimension.
So there's, like, the extra, like, white...
The white highlights and everything.
And...
Um...
And, like, for the transparency.
Especially the trophy, too.
The white highlights and the dark...
The dark highlights, too.
Um...
I recommend copying the left side of the seat so that art is covered less.
Left side.
Oh, these?
Oh, it's not covering that much, to be honest.
It's literally just...
It's just the bottom.
I swear you guys are not missing much.
You guys are not missing much from the artwork, guys.
I swear to God.
Like, I did say, oh, it's cut out.
But it was literally just a tiny bit.
It's just...
It's a very...
It's tiny.
I swear.
I swear, guys.
You're not missing...
Okay.
All right.
I'll make it...
I'll make it so you guys can see it better.
Okay, guys.
Okay.
I'll make it so you guys can see it better.
See, I told you.
You're not missing much.
That's really it.
That's all here.
Okay.
Ha -ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Um...
This is like...
Cute, morbidly.
Oh, and then there's everybody here at the bottom.
Didn't see everybody here.
Okay, wait.
Maybe you are missing much.
Maybe.
No, because you're not supposed to be right.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Okay, there we go.
Ha-ha-ha-ha.
Oh, there we go.
Is that- is that better?
Is that- is that- is that- is that better now, guys?
Is that, uh, we told you.
Well, I didn't want you guys to be right.
You know, I'm the streamer.
Sometimes I want to be right.
I want to rewrite history.
I like how someone's like, I need all the pixels.
I like how the whole gang's here, down here.
The whole gang's here.
Wait, is this the right one?
Okay.
This one's by DarlingDCT3.
Oh, there's the GamerSauce logo.
Her art style is so clean.
Oh my gosh.
And then this is my accurate- by the way, because I'm wearing a sportswear.
Sports bra.
This is like the accurate size.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, the nails too.
I didn't realize there was nail- the- the- like she got the nails in too.
Um, this is like one of my older, older outfits, but like pre-Thief outfit too.
Um.
This is also by Darling.
So, uh, in a different outfit.
Um, I like how like a lot of people, when they submitted entries, they submitted like entries with different outfits.
Just for the sake of like, you know, diversifying.
Um.
And, oh, it's so cute.
I love the little details too.
Like you can even have- even the nails are there.
Like the little nails sticking out.
And then the stars coming out of the trophy.
And then the trophy!
GamerSauce logo on the trophy!
Oh my god.
And oh my god, this- use the screen tones is so well done from a lot of them.
Um, as the shading.
Cause it could just have been like, you know, it could honestly been just like a flat shading.
But the fact that a lot of these artists use screen tone to like, um, accentuate the- the shading a lot more.
Make it pop out more.
Um, it's a very nice touch.
I like the little details.
Uh, this is by DokoroDX.
Um.
This face is so well done.
Uh, I- I- I don't know.
It's just the hair details and the way the face is drawn is like incredibly- Like it's- it's like very stylistic.
And then like the little smoke from the gun too.
Or not from the gun, but like the environment.
Um, I don't know.
You guys look like ghosts.
Maybe you guys like-
You guys are like ghosts.
Like the dragoons I killed.
And you're haunting me.
You're here to haunt me.
Um, there's a rock and roll from, uh, Dreams Run Deep.
Uh, oh, I like how you guys are like- Just like, groupies.
You look like- You guys look like groupies in the show.
I just noticed.
Let me uh- Let me pop this up, boy.
Oh my god.
You guys look like you're part of the groupie gang.
Let me move- Actually, let me move my- Boop, boop, boop.
There we go.
By the way, chat, um...
When I selected...
Uh...
Oh my gosh, I just- I- I'm sorry if you guys didn't make it past the first round.
When my assistant was judging it.
But we had to narrow it down to 150- Like, we had to narrow it down to 150.
Like, I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry if you didn't make it to the first round- Like, the first round of- Of judging.
It was very difficult.
Uh, this is by EZD.
Uh, I like how instead of a gun, they used a water gun.
To be like, PG.
They're like, are we allowed to depict guns?
In the waifu cup?
So they swa- I like to think that's where their mind was.
Uh, when they were like, do I use water gun instead of gun?
Um, just to make sure, like, it fits.
Oh yeah, she's shooting!
Yeah, I'm shooting like- Like I say, she.
That's not me.
I like how- I like how I'm shooting like- Gamersub liquids into you.
I was like, drink some gamersubs!
Um...
Then there's like the little dragon and the little tomato in the top.
Uh, this one's by, uh- Wait.
Um...
LRESEC.
Uh, so...
I don't know what it is about the face.
The face is like...
Just- Just really nicely- It's- The face is just so pretty.
Um, in general.
I like how this looks like- You're a Naruto person.
Haha!
Naruto!
Yeah, your eyes go straight to the face when you look at this piece of artwork.
And then there's tomato me.
Um...
I don't know what's wrong with this dragon.
He looks like he's- He looks like he is- Oh, she's Naruto instead of me.
But- Um, the face is just very captivating.
And my eyes go straight to it, which is really nice.
And when I saw like the different colors- I really like how it works with different colors.
Especially the background too.
I think the background looks really nice with all the different colors and everything.
It's not a face.
Bop.
Um, this one's also by EllerySec.
Uh, and the fact that, you know, I'm painting the gamer- I think I- I really like- Oh, and then look!
Look at the top!
Look at this!
Look at- Oh my god!
The top!
It's so cute!
Haha!
I like the little- The little silhouettes!
At the top!
That's such a little- That's such a cute extra thing, you know?
Um, there's such a cute feature over there.
Yeah, the little details of the top part here.
Um, and then the shade- Oh my gosh, the shading for this.
Really well done.
Um, this is by EllyWife.
But- Uh, haha!
Just showing my...
Assets.
I don't know what else to say.
They- They- They- The- The- I would call- I call this the Marvel DC pose.
Cause you know how, like, back in the day, uh, Marvel and DC comic- I don't know if they still do it, but Marvel and DC comic book covers would be like...
Boob.
Butt.
The Black Widow pose!
Yeah!
I call this the Black Widow pose!
Haha!
Um, this one's by...
Uh, FluffyCatfish.
I- I really like this unique take they went with it.
Because, um...
I felt like, you know...
Especially with the way they put the text at the bottom.
So people who don't know who I am would be like, Who's this girl- Who is this waifu on the waifu cup?
So they can go straight and be like, Ah, Doki Bird.
Haha!
So, I like that as the touch.
Where- Where you- And then, like, the fact that the gamer sub logo is, like, within the liquid bubbles and everything.
Um...
I...
And then there's the tomato right here.
It's like, hey!
But I like the composition for this.
Just because it's- It is different from the other entries.
Um, and has its own- It's a different theme.
Uh...
Uh, compared to the others.
And then there's...
Uh, this one's by...
Flixtamo?
I...
Well, you know what's going on.
I'm just like...
Well...
Yeah.
Yeah!
I like the eyes.
I mean...
Yeah!
Guys, eyes are up here!
Haha!
The eyes are up here!
We're no- Nothing underneath!
Guys!
Hehehe!
All right, and then there's Guy Keary.
Um...
I like the...
I- I really like how the trophy is drawn.
The thing I liked about this one was the fact that the transparency was very well balanced in a way that the transparency is here, but then it's balanced by other colors in the back too.
And I really loved how the trophy was done with the GamerSub logo here and then the tomato form in the trophy and everything.
Yeah, it's like an anime credit scene or opening.
And everything.
I think we all know who wins.
No, you guys don't understand.
When you see all the... Guys, we're only at entry 38 out of a hundred and...
Guys, we are not even half... Guys, no, you don't understand.
We're not even halfway.
Halfway, chat.
Haha, haha.
This is from Giant Fluffy.
This is a very different art style too.
I like how... Oh my God.
What is this?
Oh, the GamerSub logo is on the coins and the trophy!
Yeah!
So all the dragons are here.
This is a very different style from the other styles that we've seen.
And then there's like the coin, the GamerSub logo is on the coins.
And then, you're in my hat right there!
You're gonna have a safe landing!
All the other dragons are gonna die, but like, especially the egg.
But like, don't worry, you have the Hatter's Cushion!
You're gonna live!
This one's by John Fluffy.
And we have here... wait, am I dead?
Wait, wait a minute.
The evil is no more.
So instead of a water gun, I have a real gun now.
So I have a real gun now instead of a water gun.
I like the background, I like the screen tone of it.
Oh my gosh, there's so many screen tones.
I like how it looks like a manga, like a panel from a manga as well.
Get down!
No, he's alive!
I'm alive, guys!
I'm just sleeping.
So this is by GrimSilvers.
And the tomato is just sleeping, guys.
I'm just sleeping.
And honestly, like... oh my god.
Whoa.
Anyway...
I really like all the details on this one too, especially the colors and the shading.
And how the clothes were drawn in general.
It's almost been an hour, we're only 30 in.
It's so over.
Saigo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, they're all so good.
They're all really good.
Look, I'm building up the anticipation and the hype.
And then there's another one by GrimSilvers.
The details on this one is really nice, especially the shading in general.
And... oh my gosh, I love how... I love how Meimei is drawn here.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
And then the outfit transparency too.
That's so cute.
And then the... you're like... the little...
Oh my god, there's the tomato dragon!
I don't know what the last one is, but I assume it's an egg.
But like the... I love the dessert for this.
Like each of the details on this is so pretty.
And then the gamer sub logo is the glasses.
This is also by Grim.
GrimSilvers sent in a lot of entries and they were all really good.
Um...
As you can tell...
This one is dedicated to like...
A particular set of fans.
Um...
That's...
That's all I'll say.
Sadly, I'm not one of those types of fans.
So it didn't give GrimSilvers an upper hand when it came to like the judgement of this particular entry.
So um...
He didn't bribe me with anything regarding like particular interests there.
Uh...
But like I said, like all his entries...
The details are just...
Like really pretty.
Um...
This one is from Hattie Ruto.
Uh...
This one is...
This outfit we don't see quite often.
We don't see...
A lot of people...
When we looked at the outfits...
It was mostly...
Uh...
People will focus on...
Alt girl Doki.
But nobody...
Uh...
Really...
Um...
Has noticed like the other outfits.
Which this one was included in one of them.
Um...
This is...
I...
I don't know.
Comfy Doki?
I don't know what...
How...
What to call this outfit.
Uh...
Sister Doki?
I guess we could call it Sister Doki.
Uh...
Sayso?
Do we call it Sayso Doki?
Um...
So I guess we'll call it...
Either Sayso or Sister.
Do we call it Sayso...
Sayso Doki?
Okay.
This one is...
So...
This is Sayso Doki.
So we don't see this...
Outfit a lot.
But...
It's very...
Simple.
But like...
Um...
It looks really nice.
Uh...
In its simplicity.
Especially with the...
I like the line art of it too.
The line art of...
Of this one.
Line art is very hard.
So I really appreciate it.
And this one is by...
Uh...
Hitominty.
Another Sayso Doki.
But you...
Dragons are in it too!
Dragons are there too!
Uh...
Like...
Doki.
Hahaha!
This was...
Incredibly cute.
Especially the star eyes.
I love the star eyes added in for the transparency.
And...
Um...
The fact that you guys are all here too.
So...
It looks like a...
A logo almost.
Uh...
With like...
The symmetry and everything.
And then you see the GamerSupp logo on the headband!
Guys we're almost halfway.
Guys...
Stay strong.
Hahaha!
At least you guys get to see a lot of beautiful art along the way.
This is also by Hito.
But...
I guess this is...
Like...
More show based off of Apex.
With the...
Ape...
The wingman.
And...
The...
Hahaha!
I like how it's so different between the two.
This one's more like...
Sayso.
And then...
Pre-Overwatch Doki!
That...
That's true.
Lolly thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
And this one...
Is like...
Um...
Regular Doki.
Hahaha!
Anyway...
Um...
But yeah...
Different styles too.
Like...
You can tell there's different styles that went into the two of these.
Um...
This one by...
I am...
Patty Quinn!
Um...
I love the expression.
It's so joyful.
Hahaha!
And the way the hair is done with the highlights too.
Like the high...
Like the extra shading in the hair to add more dimension.
The fact that people added extra shading and everything.
Just to like...
Make the hair pop out more.
I...
I love it.
I just love the extra-ness people went to.
Especially...
And the screen tone.
I just love the extra stuff people went into.
Because they didn't have...
They didn't just make it like super flat.
Uh...
And this one's by...
Inana?
I assume...
Sorry if I...
I'm so sorry if I butchered your name!
I'm really sorry!
Ah!
The background's really pretty.
I love the...
Um...
The fact...
The fact that the background is themed towards...
Um...
Towards...
It's the outfit as well.
Um...
And then the GamerSub logo is right here!
It's like...
Where's GamerSub logo?
There's the GamerSub logo right here.
Uh...
Yeah!
The pose is very dynamic with her...
With...
Sorry...
Her...
That's me.
With me holding...
With me holding the...
The hair too.
So it makes the...
The hair much more dynamic guys.
And then this one is...
Frale.
You might recognize Frale.
Um...
She has done a lot of Doki Bites for us.
So...
It's a very recognizable...
Artist...
Uh...
Within...
The Dragoon community.
Um...
And...
I love the use of screentone for the background.
Cause it makes it...
Pop so much.
Cause you can see in the...
Extra...
In the other backgrounds too.
You can see in the other backgrounds...
How much it...
Pop...
The main visuals are popped out.
Uh...
With the...
The screen...
Use the screentones in the back.
And...
Uh...
There's me.
And there's also me.
Yeah.
The hair is like...
Super big.
And bouncy.
And everything.
It's just very dynamic.
In general.
And then there's...
Eva4111.
There's all of you guys.
Oh!
There's all of you guys cheering!
Look at you with the pom-pom!
Oh my god!
There you are!
Cheering for me!
And then the gamer sub logo is here.
And then there's me too.
And then there's also me.
And then there's...
Yeah.
It looks like...
It looks...
It looks like it comes from...
Um...
An anime.
Oh!
And yeah.
The anime.
The eyes are really pretty.
Uh...
If you look at the other colors with the...
With the drinks and stuff.
It's the eye...
The eye...
The shape...
The way the eyes are done so that a little bit of the drink color comes out too.
I like that.
I really like that.
Uh...
Yeah.
It looks like straight out of a manga panel.
Or like anime.
Um...
Yeah.
And then a little shadow too.
Like...
To add more dimension too.
To separate the background from...
Uh...
The piece.
It's so hard.
Guys we're at...
Remember when I said we're halfway?
We're not actually halfway.
I lied.
I just wanted to make you guys feel like time is passing by faster.
Uh...
We're...
We're only at...
We're at 49.
We're at...
Um...
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna have to go a little quicker guys.
I'm sorry I can't talk long.
Um...
I wanna give a long commentary on each piece.
But we're gonna have to go a little faster.
I'm sorry.
I can't talk long.
I need to do this.
49 out of 115.
Um...
This is by EXO-POD.
Umm...
The fact that I'm like crawling out of your...
Out of your games of101 Cup, as if I'm on like, uh...
The ring.
I'm like.
Sorry, I think we're in it.
I'm pretty sure like we're in a generation where the ring is slowly becoming irrelevant.
I have not heard about the ring in a long time.
I know in Japan they made like more more movies regarding the ring.
But like I think in NA they stopped after the ring tune.
But yeah, it looks like I'm coming out of this the gamer subs cup from the ring.
I really like that though.
Like I'm like drink your gamer sub.
This is by JingJang.
I just like how there's like a lot of stuff going on.
Like when you just look at it, you can't see everything at once.
So there's like so much so many details going in.
And the fact that like you can look at it every time and you'll see find something new.
So there's always There's always like more like there's always something new to go into.
Oh my god, I have four favorites now.
We're not even halfway and you already have four favorites.
But yeah, the amount of details on this is just breathtaking.
And this one's about Karas Regaza.
I like how you guys are my ammunition.
Goodbye.
And the expression too, I love the expression on this.
I know exactly what I'm doing.
You know, I know exactly what's happening.
It's very fitting.
Yeah.
But yes, I'm going a lot a little bit faster now.
I'm really sorry.
There's a lot.
I like this because the cup is also like the details on the cup too, but this is a different style.
This is by KG Hazard and it reminds me of like retro style for Retro Doki.
And oh yeah, the hair details too, like the curls and everything.
And I love how like she even like did something with drew more like drew stuff for the cup as well.
And most of the transparency is coming from the liquid coming out of the cup.
As well as like mini like highlights.
She used the transparency for the highlights, the eyes, and the liquid coming out of the cup.
Which I feel is like different from a lot of the other entries.
So I do like how creative they went with it.
And the design itself is like you don't see the retro design style a lot often.
This is by Kisu VT.
Bang bang.
The finger guns.
I like the pose of this because of the fact that the hand is getting closer to the screen.
To the like getting closer to you as well.
So there's like this perspective of everything.
So I do like the perspective of this.
And also like the hair too.
Oh my gosh, the way the hair is done.
The details in the hair is so pretty.
Like I just love how people draw hair.
I don't know what else to say.
Like I'm really jealous of people who can draw hair really well.
Like this is a really well drawn hair.
Like it looks so nice and smooth.
I want to touch it.
But don't touch people's hair without like their consent.
Like don't do that.
That's weird.
Like please ask somebody who won't touch their hair.
Because that's that's fucking weird.
If somebody touches my hair randomly.
Like I'm like bro what the fuck.
Like bro.
Please.
I will call HR.
Bro that's weird.
It's weird.
It's okay.
People can touch my hair.
I am bald.
This one is by KittyKatVaT.
Look at you guys.
There you guys are.
Look at the two wagons.
Oh and then there's a city in the background.
So it's like based off of like my old videos.
It's all like my old background.
Jacob A.
Thank you for the Jacob.
Oh I like how you had the pronunciation next to your name.
And I still said it wrong.
Cause I don't read fully.
Jacob B.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And your very first super chat too.
Hey doki.
Today is my birthday.
Guys,
we're almost halfway there for real now.
I'm not joking this time.
We're like at 55.
This one's by Kivonababu.
Okay, Kivonababu.
I love the tomato expression here.
I also really like the name too that's added there because it lets people know like that's me.
And then the extra like the background is not just fully white.
They added like little details in there as if there's like smoke coming in the back.
And the trophy itself too with the extra dimension with the colors.
And I think like with in the different colors it really like pops out in whatever liquid color you use too.
So this one's really nice.
I love also the tomato expression.
The tomato expression at the top right?
It adds a nice touch.
They also uploaded two artworks.
So this is Alternative Doki.
Same artist.
And I love the stickers on the trophy.
I don't think... I don't know of any of the... I don't remember the other artist.
I don't know if I've done that.
But like I know like the trophy has been added for a lot of entries.
But the sticker... the cups... the trophy stickers really adds more to it.
Adds more to the design and everything.
Also the expression is so cute.
It's such a cute expression.
All right.
This one's by kankonpeito.
And we have Seisodoki again.
And then this time you're all sleeping with me.
We're all... except for you.
You're... I think you're a plushie.
I love how the other dragoons are like actual...
are like drag... like the dragoons.
And then this chonky goon does like...
put me out of my misery.
Like chonky goons are being crushed right now.
Like please mother.
He's just... He's just extra cuddly guys.
He's just extra cuddly... deflated goon...
but I do like the composition of this... like a different take... of just... like it's just like cuddling with the plushie... And just enjoying comfy times with the dragon.
And this one's by coolit.
Oh wait it's a circle.
Oh my god.
So instead of a rectangle...
rectangular box... I'm going alright.
I like it.
Yeah we love this...
we're going with...
It's a circle and the hair is like... it's like a little hula hoop thing, like a ring.
So the hair is like... the hair is like looped around the hula hoop and everything.
And then the fact that like the shoe is not just full black, so they added the transparency too.
And oh my god, it's a circle instead of a square!
That's so creative with what they did here.
It's almost... yeah, it's almost like Sailor Moon-like too.
It's very... oh, and the gamer slubs is part of the hula hoop.
The ring.
Oh, that's so pretty.
Alright, guys, we're halfway now.
We did it!
We fucking did it!
We're actually halfway now!
Guys, we did it!
It only took us an hour.
For real.
It only...
It only took us an hour, but we're halfway!
This is by Kuni17.
I like the little crown on top.
It reminds me of like... like doodling and stuff too.
Took us a lot of time, but we're all... we're there.
Yeah, it has like Scott Pilgrim!
You're right!
It does remind me of Scott... Scott... Scott Pilgrim.
Scott Pilgrim.
I like that.
We're getting erzhled paths.
When you are happy, it's a bad time.
We made it to the spinal cord, the lights grew!
We made it to the spinal cord, and we finished this pregunta verse by songo!
Oh, we do not have any taxpayer.
We did it.
YohNan sangat!
That's so cute.
The bunny has the guitar pick too.
And then the spotlight.
You can see like the background is like a spotlight.
Free shooter!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Mostly a lurker in Clip and Joy, but wanted to say thanks for all the smiles and laughs whenever I need them the most.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
And your very first super chat too!
Thank you so much!
I really appreciate it for the support.
I hope you guys are enjoying the stream.
I know it's like different from my usual stream.
And we're just looking through art and everything.
But I still hope you guys are having a good time just enjoying looking at the art.
And like enjoying the different artworks that were submitted for the Gamers Up Waifu Cup Contest.
People are just so talented.
Everybody is just so freaking talented, you know?
Yeah, we're on 60.
This is by KuromikiMT.
Magic the Gatherer.
MTG.
I assume MTG means Magic the Gathering, right?
Anytime I see MTG, I just think Magic the Gathering.
But yeah, I love how a lot of people who did the background, it's just a solid black.
But then they did like, they made it more eye-catching with the fact that it's not just a solid black background.
But they added like, stripes in there to give it more like, pop-ness.
And then...
Oh, hey look, there's me too.
There's me.
And there's also me.
Yeah, it's a nice... it's a different style from the usual.
So I really... I just really like the stylistic choice with the background especially too.
And then they use the screen tone as the shading here.
Like there's the extra dark shading and then there's screen tone shading.
Alright, and then there's Lap Herb.
Oh, the eyes!
Wait, this eye style is so... and also gun.
This is not PG anymore.
I keep forgetting, like I've been trying to like, mentally...
I have a mental block right now in terms of swearing because of the sponsor stream earlier.
You know when I said like, in the beginning of the sponsor stream, I was like, fuck.
And I was like, wait, can I swear?
And then my staff... one of my staff members that worked on this sponsor instantly messaged me and was like, you're not supposed to swear.
They like... they like instantly messaged me.
It's like, you're not supposed to swear.
Please, please make sure you don't swear and... or keep it minimum.
So I have... I have like a mental block right now.
So I... I'll get... I'll get rid of it once soon.
It just takes me a couple of hours.
It just... it'll take a couple of hours but...
I'll start swearing again, don't worry.
Oh my gosh, and then you got... I like how you have like, your own mini gun too.
The dragons have their own mini gun.
And then...
And then... oh the eye style is like, really pretty in general.
It's such a pretty eye.
The eye style in general too.
Oh my god, and then the gun.
The gun, oh my god.
So pretty.
Alright, and then we have Lemmy Zest here.
Doki bird.
The detail is really nice.
I do enjoy...
Sorry, I have to look at this again.
I just realized the eye...
Like, it's just something about the eyes.
Like, the eyes are so captivating here.
I just... I just can't look away from the eye.
It's just so captivating.
Anyway, I love all the little details.
There's dragoons cheering in the...
I love the little dragoon pom-pom.
Look at this guy.
He's like, Hey.
Hey, I'm here too.
Hey.
He's just like, hey.
But yeah, you guys...
Like, there's Baobao here, squishing his cheekies with me.
And then there's me using you as a stress ball.
I want to make dragoon stress balls in the future.
Like, whenever I can finally make merch again.
I want to...
I actually really want to make...
I just really want to make dragoon, like...
Squishies, you know?
Like, those stress squishies.
So I can be like...
I just think it'd be really cute.
This is by Linaria Munkin.
I...
Oh my gosh.
I love the expression of the tomato.
I'll be like...
I can like, squish the dragoon squishy.
But...
I found the tomato expression is really...
It's like...
The tomato expression and...
Oh my gosh, my expression too.
Wait, I mean, they're both my expression.
So both of my expressions were really nicely drawn here.
And then I like how...
For this outfit, a lot of people put the gamer stuff low.
Like the logo on the star.
Or replacing the star too.
Yeah, it's like Kirby!
It is!
You're right!
It's like a little Kirby.
Kirby, Kirby, Kirby.
Freeze,
thank you for the...
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Hope you enjoy your stay.
Okay, this is by Leo Wart.
So, alternative doki.
Oh my gosh.
You guys are so...
Like a lot of the artist...
The expression is just so...
Like...
I just can't keep my eyes off of the expression all the time.
Because like...
The way you guys draw faces...
It's just like...
I always just...
I want to look at the face.
Like my eyes can't...
Can't look away from the face a lot of the times.
And it's so cute.
It's really cute.
It's very mischievous too.
And then the little sparkles like cameras like...
Doki, look over here!
Look over here, Doki!
What are you wearing?
Gamers up.
I'm wearing gamers up.
Also, I got an update from my assistant.
The sticker pack is not gacha.
If you buy the bundle, you get the whole five...
You get all the stickers.
So, it's not gacha.
Thank you for the correction.
But only if you buy the bundle.
Oh my god you're wearing a little gamer stuff hat and then I don't think the to miss hey I'm like a parasite so this is like retro doki before she got like I'm like the tomato is like a parasite so you know like those like parasites that consume that like consume like insect brains the one that's based off Last of Us is based off of that parasite or fungus.
That's me.
So this RetroDoki was just in time to avoid the infection.
Yeah, the cordyceps.
I'm basically like a cordyceps.
Say what you like about the 4Kids, but the Kirby opening was a banger.
And Meta Knight's English voice actor was a great fit.
Lali, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Honestly, I think the majority of the 4Kids openings, especially the One Piece one...
I think 4Kids was really good with making...
English openings for Japanese songs.
I feel like... I personally think it's just really well done.
And they're very catchy.
I might not have grown up with Butterfly, but come on.
Digimon, Digital Monsters, Digital Monsters Champion.
We might have like four lines, but like...
It was at least catchy.
It was at least... It was at least very catchy.
Gotta go fast.
Gotta go faster, faster, f-f-f-f-faster.
Sonic, b-b-b-b-sonic.
They're really easy to sing.
Yeah, Butterfly sounds beautiful, but like...
Is it easy to sing?
At least a child.
Can sing Digimon.
At least a child can sing Digimon.
Digimon, Digital Monsters.
Digital Monsters Champion.
Anyway.
But yeah, this is from Lumenshot.
Alright.
This is also by Lumenshot.
Oh, that's very smug of you.
Also like, I know like the dragon in this...
Particular outfit is like very...
Don't boo her, she's right!
Wait, there was another song that's like...
What was that other Digimon song?
Whenever like...
Whenever they accomplish something, they play that song.
God, what was it?
It was so ca- Not gonna lie.
Please...
Please love the art.
The art are cool.
Very cool.
Thank you for the super chat, Rip.
Thank you.
Yeah, this art style is really nice.
And then the details of the hair too.
The bold...
The line art...
Wait.
Like the boldness of the line art here and the balancing of that is really well done.
Hey Digimon.
That's my butterfly.
That's...
Hey Digimon.
Digimon.
You wouldn't ever ask for Durch PR.
You would never ask for...
Bang...
Bang TBD.
That's my butterfly.
That's my coastal.
You guys might have Japanese Hamtaro, but we have Ham Ham Hamtaro.
How did it go?
How did the English Hamtaro song go?
I didn't have that.
I didn't forget.
It took me a while.
It's Hamtaro time.
That's right.
OK, you guys.
Oh, I'm sorry.
This is like I'm sorry.
This is important.
We'll be back to schedule the contest result.
Please.
Hamtaro song was so good.
OK.
OK, the Hamtaro song is so good.
It's so good.
OK, is it this one?
Wait, I got to make sure you guys don't hear it, too.
OK.
Best friends.
Ba-ba-ba-dum.
Bye, best friends.
OK, there you go.
Oh, there you go.
Hamtaro opening.
English.
This is my... This is...
This is my Hamtaro.
Is it this?
Oh, my God.
Where is it?
Guys, this is so important.
No, you don't understand.
OK, the credits, too.
Ba -ba-ba-dum.
Ba-ba-ba-dum.
That's the credits.
I'm running in, ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-da-dum.
Ba-da-ba-ba-dum.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-dum.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-da-da-dum.
Ba-ba-dum.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-dum.
Ba-dum.
I told you, it's so good.
They'll never have this.
They can't take this away from us.
Anyway, back to...
They can't take this away.
They can make fun of us all they want.
But to us, those were bangers.
It was bangers.
To us, it was bangers.
They can't make fun of us, but we know this is what true music was like.
Wmercy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Instead of a version I didn't have but can instantly recognize, we had this version I grew up with but don't remember.
Thank you for the super chat, Wmercy.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I recognize it.
It just took...
Do you remember the Japanese Kirby opening?
I thought so.
That's right.
Kirby, Kirby, Kirby, but...
To be fair, it was mostly just him saying Kirby.
So it was very easy...
To be fair, it was very easy to remember because all he said was Kirby.
So that's why...
That's why I could remember it really well.
Alright, anyway.
Level 1 nod.
I really love the chat.
Sorry, back to our regular scheduled...
Art contest.
Back to...
Back to our regular scheduled...
Art contest.
I mean, the Sonic one is just gotta go fast.
Yeah, but that's why it's stuck in your head.
Gotta go fast.
Gotta go faster, faster, f-f-f-faster.
Ba-ba-ba-da.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-da-ba.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
All right.
Anyway, Level 1 nod.
I love the extra shading on the trophy there.
Because it gives like...
It makes it like so...
The trophy looks so 3D.
Not gonna lie.
I really love it.
And then like...
Uh...
The way the composition is, like, uh, the placements of everything is really nicely done.
We will never escape.
Whose fault is it?
Who started this compo-...
It wasn't me.
I didn't start this conversation.
I take zero blame in this.
I just got dragged in.
I got dragged in into this.
This is by LxNal.
Oh no, no.
Can you guys give me... Oh my god!
I didn't realize the little details with like the characters on the red pocket envelopes too.
Like all the dragoons here and then the tomato and then the long goons too.
Oh and the details on the dragon as well.
And the detail...
The very accurate representation of me.
It's in the details, guys.
It's the details, guys.
Anyway, I really like all the little details they added in general because it's just...
You can tell like lots of effort was put in the line art and everything.
Just the little tiny things there.
Very authentic.
Like I'veolve selection is dedicated and endorsed by Doki bird.
This one's by Madeley The thing I really liked about this is the background.
The background is... you look at the background.
They're like tiny dragoons everywhere, and they're all like... the fact that the entire background is just...
Tiny dragoons!
Like the little...
The effort put into that, the patterning and everything, and then the fact that, like, I think, like, the color-wise is, like, very well balanced, too.
Like, I, like, the red really fits the tomato.
Yeah, um, yeah, so, like, these are all the dragoon souls I've consumed.
Every time you join your membership, your... every time you join the membership, um, your soul is mine.
So, these are all the member goons here, um, who, like, who have absorbed their soul inside me.
And I've trapped them into this liminal... this black hole.
Every soul I consume, I get stronger.
Oh, look, it's me!
Yeah, you see yourself?
I see you guys!
The boy goons are real.
You're here forever.
Um, this is by, uh, Mange... I don't know how to pronounce this.
Mange... Jew?
Um... the style is really beautiful.
Um...
And then there's... I love the small... you know, like, what is that Rick and Morty part where it was, like, little faces?
This is what the tomato reminds me of!
Awesome, Powerball!
Thank you for the 10 gift ships!
Thank you, thank you!
I love how... what is it?
Little bites?
You know?
And then, um...
And then the little bits, yeah!
This is what the face reminded me of.
Because it looks like I have a very tiny little...
A little bit's face.
A little bite's face.
But I really love this style in general.
And it's just the little shading colors too of the hair.
The hair!
The way the hair is drawn as well.
And then, throw their souls in!
Blinko, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hi Doki!
I saw a bunch of stans at NYC selling Doki Bird art when I went to the concert there.
I love your clips!
I'm so hyped to grab this!
GG Bunda!
The art is mine!
I know!
It's so... oh my god, it's so... it's really hard.
It was really difficult to pick.
But I'm super excited that it's finally... we got the hardest part done.
Like, we got the hardest part done, finally.
But yeah, the name of the gamer sub logo is the hat.
And I just love how the hair is drawn.
It's just so pretty.
Like, it's just really dynamic in general, the way the hair is drawn.
Alright, this one.
Whoa!
My eyes are up here.
This was by Mafuki, not safe for work.
Guys, it's not safe for work, so don't open their profile at work, guys.
Like, it literally tells you it's not safe for work.
This is safe for work.
This is just suggestive.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for throwing another soul into the ship, Yoko.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, as a parasite, I have successfully attached myself to her.
Guys, it's alright.
Alright, but yeah, I love, like...
I just... the pose is nice.
What can I say?
The pose...
Okay, guys, I'm gonna skip a little bit because I...
Speaking of not safe for work...
Guys, I need you guys...
Are you guys...
Okay, guys, the next one I'm gonna show you, I'm skipping...
I'm not skipping, but I wanted to, like...
I really want to show this next one right now.
Because I figured, like, might as well, since we're talking about not safe for work.
So, if you're at work, just be advised...
Just be advised.
Just...
Anyway...
Sorry, I forgot their...
Their...
Their actual Twitter name is Linebreaker.
But it's not safe for work, by the way.
I just forgot to put that here.
Their actual Twitter is Line...
Oh, it's Virtual Graves.
By the way, this is Virtual Graves.
You might recognize them.
You might...
I like how the tomato has a bikini.
You guys don't know who Virtual Graves is.
They've done a lot in the VTuber community.
So, there's this one, too.
Since we're talking about not safe for work, I might as well just show these right off the bat.
And this one is by...
I can feel its gravitational pull.
They have their own gravity.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We got easy win.
Anyway, this is my Titan Gold.
And...
Yeah.
I like that.
I like the hard thing.
Like, whoa.
I'm just really happy about gamer subs.
I just love gamer subs so much.
Oh, my God.
Gamer subs.
Wow.
Did someone just use my gamer sub code, DokiBird?
By the way, guys.
I forgot to show about it.
But if you use my code, DokiBird, at gamer subs, you get 10% off on all earnings.
Whoa.
I love gamer subs.
Wow.
Gamer subs.
Okay.
Back to the other entries.
I think these are the two not-safe-for-work entries.
Anyway.
We have...
Wait.
Can I have...
My mom made a code.
Okay.
I'm going to pin your message.
I should have had that pinned at the very beginning.
I'm sorry.
I forgot to have that pinned at the very beginning.
Anyway.
Here's another one by...
Here's another one by Matt.
Desenhero.
And I like that.
I like how this looks like I'm driving a trophy.
Like, it feels like...
It just feels like I'm reading a comic book.
I really like the comic book panel.
And it looks like I'm driving a trophy.
I love the hair, too.
It's like...
It's such a stylistic way of drawing hair, as well.
And I'm like, whoa.
Yeah, it feels like a mecha.
Yeah.
You're just like, wow, we're going really fast.
Anyway.
Chonky Goons couldn't fit in the trophy, so you guys got left out.
You guys got left on the side of the road.
I'm sorry.
There had to be one.
You guys picked the shortest straw.
Anyway.
Here's the next one by Megan Yulee.
I love...
Like, this style reminds me of, like, shoujo manga style, especially the eyes, too.
It reminded me heavily of shoujo manga.
You know what?
It reminds me of skip beat, I think.
Like, the way that...
I feel like I'm reading, like, the classic shoujo manga.
What was that publisher?
The publisher that makes, like...
Makes, like...
Like, who publishes specifically on...
By the way, do you guys know skip beat is still ongoing?
Like, I was so surprised.
I was like...
Oh, my...
Skip beat has been going on for a long time.
It's still ongoing.
Yeah, clap.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like...
Yeah!
My Hero Academia ended, but skip beat is still going strong.
Yeah, it is!
I was literally looking up on it recently.
It's basically, like, an OG classic shoujo manga.
It's just about, like, this girl who, like, basically becomes an actress to get revenge...
Like, get revenge on her ex-boyfriend because her ex-boyfriend used her to become an actor.
So, like, she was, like, his personal maid.
And then, like, she was so heartbroken that she was like, I'm gonna become an actress and I'm gonna be better than you at acting.
I don't even know what her goals are anymore.
Like, I don't even...
Yeah, like, I was like, it's still ongoing.
Is she not a better actress yet?
Did she not win an Oscar yet?
I don't know what's going on anymore.
I don't know what's going on in skip beat.
But I'm just like...
I'm just like...
Did she do it?
Did she not?
Like, it's been 10 years.
Like, it's been 22 years.
Like, is she still acting?
Like, is she not...
Did she not win awards yet?
Damn you, Toki.
I wanna know now.
Skip beat and cliff notes, please.
Yeah, so like, I don't know.
I don't know if she...
Clearly she hasn't become a better act...
I don't know.
She clearly hasn't been a better actress yet.
Cause she's...
The manga is still going on.
So like, I assume that like, she's still competing against her ex.
I assume...
The skip beat is real.
So...
Anyway.
We have this one by Maya VT.
Guys, I think one of my favorite things too...
About looking at all the different art styles...
Is the way people draw eyes.
I think like...
Like, each artist...
Oh, and especially...
Oh my gosh.
Like, the details on the clothes too.
Like, the clothing flip fold and everything.
And the shading here.
To accentuate certain aspects.
That is 100% true, by the way.
Yeah, this one...
I love the...
The way that eyes are drawn.
And like, good shading.
I love this part of the shading.
Like, good job.
And then their GamerSub logo on the ruffles too.
The GamerSub logo on the ruffles.
Oh, that's very creative!
Now that I think about it.
That's...
That's really creative.
Anyway.
This part is...
The...
The chef's kiss.
Mwah.
That's the...
That's the chef's kiss.
That's the chef's kiss right here.
Here we have...
From MewChub.
Oh, it's so like...
I look so innocent here.
Which is also very accurate too.
And then I like how the GamerSub logo is the pin on my shirt.
It's like the pin or button on my shirt.
And there's also me.
This is before the parasite attached to her.
Yeah, it looks like an anime style.
Yeah.
It looks like from an anime.
And it reminds me of a particular anime style.
Oh, what is it?
Is it Fullmetal Alchemist?
Like there's something...
I think it sort of reminds me of Fullmetal Alchemist style a little bit too.
So like this is like RetroDoki.
Before the parasite infected her.
Or K-On!
Yeah!
K-On!
K-On too!
Yeah, I can see the K-On.
Oh my.
Oh my god.
Do people even remember K-On?
I never watched K-On.
But...
I really liked their figures.
Because back then...
K-On was everywhere.
Like...
Figure wise.
Like there was so many...
So much merchandise of K-On stuff.
And I never watched K-On.
But I really liked the merch.
So I bought like...
You know how like each girl has their own figure?
And everything.
And you're supposed to collect all the girls to make like the band?
Um...
I just bought one of them.
Because I just thought she was the cutest.
So I bought the one on the piano.
With the bushy eyebrows.
That's the only one I bought.
I was like...
You will be alone forever.
I will not buy any other girl.
You will be...
I just...
I literally just bought her.
With the piano.
And then...
And then I was just like...
That is it.
You...
You will have no one else.
I don't even know who she is.
I just thought she was the cutest figure out there.
Like you know...
Because you're supposed to have all of them.
To make the full band.
You don't need anyone else.
That's true.
I literally...
When I had like a figure case.
I just...
She just...
I was like...
You're supposed to put her with the other girls.
To make the band.
And I'm just...
I just put her in it.
Alright.
Anyway.
This one is by MeKQX.
Oh my gosh.
I love like...
The pose is really nice.
It's so dynamic too.
Like...
Especially the hand.
The fact that the hand is like bigger.
So that it's like...
She's like...
It's like...
It's like the perspective.
Yeah, that's the word.
The perspective is really nice here too.
And like the shading as well.
This is a different type of shading than you see usually.
It's a lot more like...
Pop out, I guess.
That's the word.
Definitely pops out a little bit...
More regarding the shading here.
It's different.
It's definitely different from...
The other art pieces in terms of it.
And we have Momo Iru.
Oh, that's so adorable.
It's so...
It's so adorable!
And then we have the tomato down here.
She's like...
She doesn't know what's gonna happen!
She's in my life!
Your life is mine!
This is the little guy.
A gremlin tomato...
A dubious little creature.
And he went...
I'm glad he didn't hurt myself.
But I like... I really... Oh, and then like the gamer stuff's here and then the gamer stuff's here.
So you see like both the gamer stuff logos on either side.
It's just really cute in general.
It's like a very simple and cute art for the waifu cup.
And then we have Moon D.Y.
art.
Oh my gosh, the details.
Sorry, whenever I see myself, I just can't help but...
just...
I can't help it.
I do like the details in this one and I just feel the aura, you know?
I just I can't help but laugh because I feel the aura coming off of the tomato.
Yeah, the inner gremlin just comes out the moment I see it.
It just comes out.
And Zonnerman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
When you look up the account and you're already following, which one?
Which...
All of them?
All the... not the, the very suggestive ones?
Like Limebreaker?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, but I love the details and then the little blush here too.
The little blush here for the artwork and all the details on the clothing flow too and the shading here, that's always a plus.
Whenever I see shading right here, I'm like good job.
You already mastered.
But yes, the shading is really nice and well done.
And then the little details on the line work and everything.
And then we have... PKT Metal Gear Solid.
Sorry, PKT MGS.
Every time I see MGS, I just think Metal Gear Solid as well.
I love how the gamer sub logo is on the tomato itself.
Oh, it's on my ass!
You see the eyes?
I love the... I love that the gamer sub logo is on my ass here.
You see the eyes here?
And then I'm like, oops.
I'm like, oops.
And then the gamer sub logo is on my ass.
And all the dragoons being like, yay!
Donkey!
I love the face.
I just love this part the most.
Get yourself a gamer sub tramp stamp.
Get yourself a gamer sub tramp stamp, guys.
And you guys are like, yippee!
Donkey's here!
And then we have probably Melody.
And then...
There's the little tomato.
Little me getting stomped on.
And then you're an accomplice to murder plus thief.
Or murder.
It could be murder.
This could be like a piece of a body part.
And I was like, dragoon, we gotta grab this so we can destroy the evidence.
I mean, it could be murder.
It could be money.
It could be anything.
We don't know what's in the bag.
But I love how, like, I'm coming out of the rectangular box.
Because I was like, you'll never catch me alive.
I will let this dragoon die before I get caught.
But yeah, so I love how... yeah, the hands on the frame, too.
It's really creative in the way they do it.
Yeah, the heist.
The heist or murder of the century.
Alright, guys.
Eighty-one!
Oh my god, this looks like it's from an anime opening.
Oh my gosh, the background, too.
Imagine the liquid.
You can see, like, bits of the print coming out of the...
Like, you can see the bits of the print from the cup as well.
This is really cute.
This is by Purisyunblue8.
And I really love... I just think it reminds me of, like, an anime opening in general.
Yeah, it really does.
It looks like an enoki with a heart in the middle.
That's so cute.
The heart... the O turns into a heart.
And then, like, a checky!
Yeah, yeah, it's like a checky that you get at, like, a maid cafe.
And then I'm like, that'll be $50?
Guys, you don't understand.
I went to a maid cafe in Japan, and they were so expensive.
They're like, you want a photo with me?
You need to pay, like... you have to pay the VIP package.
You have to pay the VIP package.
But they'll sing you a song, too.
They'll sing you a...
Well, it's cheaper because, um...
Because, like, the US dollars at the moment is, like...
I guess, like, against the yen, it'll be cheaper.
So, like, for us, it'll be, like, $20, I think.
I don't know how the conversion rate is.
I don't know if the yen rose.
I think the yen rose, right?
It rose up, right?
I don't know.
I didn't keep track because I'm not going to Japan.
So...
So, I'm not sure.
But, like, maybe it'll be, like, $30 instead.
We have this one.
Oh, it's back down again.
I'm sorry.
10,000?
Oh, my God.
That's $70?
I remember when 10,000 yen was, like, $100.
It was, like, almost one...
It was so easy to calculate.
And now it's, like, $70.
That's crazy.
That's actually...
Wow.
God damn it, America.
This is why, for contracts now, when they're, like, do you want to be paid in American dollars or Canadian dollars?
I just be, like, American.
Trina was, like, please do not pay me in Canadian dollars.
I have an American dollar account.
I would like to receive American money.
I...
Every time, they're, like, would...
They're, like, okay, how would you like to pay?
I was, like, why transfer to my American dollar account, please?
I'm just, like...
I'm, like, I will not receive Canadian money.
Don't pay me in my monopoly money, please.
Like, it's still falling.
Walter, ask...
You ask any other Canadian.
They would rather be paid in American dollars than Canadian dollars.
You don't understand how shitty our currency is right now.
I don't understand.
Anybody would rather be paid by American money right now.
Unless it's Euros.
It's, like, Euros than American money.
Because, like, Euros is even worth more.
Like...
Not by a lot.
But, like, it's still, like, a little better.
Yeah.
Anyway, this one is by R1 Salt.
I really love the personality of this particular piece.
And the fact that, like...
I just love the...
I just love the personality and the composition of it.
Like, I know it's, like, a little bit simpler.
But especially the background, too.
The background, as well, is, like...
Is, like, really well done.
Because it fits the theme of the album.
It fits the outfit.
And the expression and the personality, like...
It's just so good.
It's, like, I basically...
Um...
Like...
Like, you lost the deal or something.
Yeah, it feels like I'm, like...
The head...
The head boss.
Or, like...
The...
You know what this reminds me of?
Um...
This reminds me of...
The aunt from Kung Fu Hustle.
That's the...
I just need a cigarette.
Like...
Yeah.
That's...
I just need...
I just need the cigarette.
Right?
Yeah.
This is...
This is what it reminds me of.
Yeah.
And the hair curls.
Um...
The badass.
Yeah.
The landlady.
I love that lady.
Yeah.
I love...
I love Kung Fu Hustle.
Uh...
She looks like she's about to sell me some Toki merch.
Cass, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Here we have...
Rare Spice.
Oh my gosh.
I like how, um...
For this one, it's like...
I'm like confined in a space.
Cause a lot of them are shows like the body.
Like the full body.
Or like, uh...
The half...
Half body?
But this one is more so focused on like the composition and like playing with the limited space they have.
Um...
So, I really like the...
Yeah.
It's like squishy.
The composition of this one is really nice.
The fact that it's like...
Um...
The composition of this one is really nice.
It's like a character select.
That's what it reminds me of, yeah.
This reminds me of like a character select menu of like...
in like a fighting game.
Or something.
Yeah.
This one, Renkai.
So cute.
There's Seisou Doki again.
I noticed a pattern.
A lot of like my...
very like, especially like the cute artists, they choose Seisou Doki.
And it really fits too.
Like it's so cute with the hugging the plushie.
And then the plushie tag is the GamerSup logo.
And you're like, this is before the infection started.
This is before I latched on to it.
But yeah, I really love... I just love how the face is done too.
It's just so soft looking.
It's just really...
Before she became an FPS gamer.
This is what she was.
This is RicardoConArt.
So...
I really love...
I just... I don't know like the whole piece itself.
It's just...
It's just really like you don't know where to...
Like it's just really well done.
Like your eyes like go everywhere because you're like looking at the details and everything.
And yeah, the background is really well done.
The fact that there's shadows.
There's like implying there's more dragoons in the back here too.
And then the dragons at the bottom and they're popping up here as well.
And the the movement of the piece is like really dynamic too.
It's just like the whole piece as well.
It's just super interesting to look at.
Yeah, guys, it was hard guys.
Now, you know why it was so hard.
I bet you guys have more than 20 of favorites right now.
And I at first had to pick one.
To be the waifu cup.
But then in the end I picked two.
I was like this is really difficult to pick one.
All right.
Here we have from Risa Twitch.
I love the background for this and like the way the hair like the face and the hair is done for this and the tomato.
Because like I like the tomatoes.
Seems like like it doesn't blend like, you know, I mean, it doesn't blend into the piece and and and there's like in the like it's like its own thing too.
So like the tomato and the Dragoon doesn't blend right in.
So I really like that about this piece that they're very it looks like it's 3D.
You know what I'm saying?
It looks like it has dimension to it.
So there's like a shadow too.
Over here.
So like this is the front.
This is like the front piece and this is like the back plate of it.
It looks it could be like an acrylic block.
So that's what I like about this piece as well.
The shading.
Yeah, the shading and everything.
All right, this one.
Okay.
Yes, this one.
Guys remember where your eyes are before I flip back guys.
And you guys remember where your eyes are.
Remember where to put your eyes.
I have 11 now.
I like that guy was like I have 10 favorite pieces.
Well now I have 11.
So this one is by Rosen Cruz.
And yeah, I'll say a lot of it.
There's a lot of very well done like from the gun.
To the line work to the shading to
Just a lot of stuff.
Yes, the hair is really nice.
There's like the line work on the hair itself too is very well done.
And I realized I have like earrings to be look at closer.
You can see there's like earrings on the ears with the chain and everything.
And it's just like the line work and shading itself is just really nice.
And the shading on the clothes and like the game like the background is a city as well.
The background over there is like the city backdrop with like the gamers up logo and everything.
And yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, and then there's another one here by Rosen.
This one is like the after party.
Yeah, party.
And this one would be like if I was able to do if I was like a lot older.
That's how I'll describe it.
I was called this piece.
What if Joki was a lot older than she is now?
This is the auntie dokey.
The auntie dokey piece.
I mean, it's the same artist and I have the same comments regarding regarding this artwork.
It is.
Wow.
Eyes are up here guys.
Eyes are up here.
Anyway.
Anyway, we're at 90.
We have 15 more to go chat 15 more to go 15 wonderful artworks to go.
So here we have Rook CL.
I love the little smoke detail.
So it's like like I'm like finger guns like bang bang and then like, you know blowing the smoke away.
So and then like I don't know if you guys could don't see it.
But the gamers up.
Logo are in the flower right here.
It's so creative.
It's like it's like the petals on the flower and then there's me also here and the fact that there's dokey in the background and it's not just a regular rectangle.
They added more dimension to the background itself.
And then the fact that I don't know the perspective is really nice because you can see that it gets smaller as you look down.
Yeah, it's like a texture too.
Yeah, it gets smaller when you look down.
So the perspective is really well.
Well done in general for this one.
I know this piece is very really very pretty.
90 where we going?
We talk Airport Ninja.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
This one is by Rook CL.
I really enjoy.
I really liked the way they did the shading for this.
I don't you see it from here the red green and blue but they put the hair shading a different color.
It flows so naturally to like the transparency.
So it looks oh my gosh when you look at the how the liquid is going to like the gamer sub drink is going to come through that the the the way it's done just looks like it just looks very natural on how like the colors come through in general like the drink comes through and I like how it has the trophy as the Oshima clip on there and there's me too.
There's me.
There's you as well.
I don't know where your hand is going.
I'm a little concerned.
But you're here too.
Here we have s2nani07262.
I like the style.
I like how I like I feel like I think this is like the clouded the clouds or I think this is like the gamer sub liquids.
The camera.
I don't know why I call it liquids, but I like how the I like.
I don't know.
Like the way this background is done is like super creative in a way.
And then there's me be like, hey, hi, I'm Paul.
That's how I see myself.
Sometimes.
Hi, I'm Paul.
Anyway, anyway, anyway, as I was saying, face is really pretty like the art style in general is just incredibly pretty in general.
And I like the fact that I don't know like the way this background is done is just I can't take my eyes off like the composition in general.
And yeah, it looks like a manga panel.
Yeah.
Yeah, I agree.
It looks like a manga panel and I'm going to be like poke and I'm just like poke.
I'm here to poke you.
All right.
92.
This is by Sarah Senia 92.
Don't wait when we actually show the results.
It's going to be a lot faster because I don't have to talk about a lot individual pieces because I already have talked about them.
So so when we get to the finalist, it'll be a lot easier because I'm just showing you guys who got picked and like tell give me my reasons why they got picked and stuff.
Yes.
So this is like parasite success.
Infection success.
So yeah reveals the tomato inside.
I really like that.
The way the way they chose the transparency for this works really well.
I mean, it's a good pick with the hair color in the trophy, but it also balances really out.
Well when I looked at like the color comparison to it balances.
Really well in general and then like how like, you know, everybody's here everybody's here with the bunnies.
There's me and the tomato and just like the line art is really beautiful.
Like the pen work in the line art.
In general.
It looks like they it looks like an inked drawing.
That's what it looks like to me.
It looks like an inked drawing here, which is really cool.
All right, this one.
This is called.
This is screet tuber.
I love the style.
It's very unique.
Like this style is very different from all the other entries.
And I like how like I'm breaking through the glass, you know?
Yeah, it's very different.
It was a very different style from a lot of the entries.
I looked at and I don't like the face.
The face is so pretty.
Yeah.
Yeah, I haven't seen this.
Dial before the fact that like it's like half lineless artwork and half line work.
So like it's just very interesting to look at in general just because it's like it's such a it's very different and it was very it's just very pretty to look at.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's just it's just like I can't stop looking at the face.
You know, but this is by screet tuber.
All right.
Seer seer.
I just I love how like mecha time.
Like the idea that I'm just getting the robot.
Like get it get in the robot.
Ducky.
Yeah.
, I just thought it was such a funny and cute piece regarding any like, hey, I'm Paul.
So I'm Paul over here.
Get in the skin suit.
Doki inside.
I don't I can't believe inside to is like the most popular animated movie.
Not in not including inflation, but that movie did not deserve to be it's a decent movie, but it's literally inside out one.
Like I don't know what to say.
It's literally inside out.
Not one, but they just added new emotion.
But yeah, I just thought it was like super creative and I love that.
I just love the way they did the tomato.
It is so funny.
This is said Bakan Ken.
I love okay.
I look did they change the shirt to the gamer stuff logo and then the trophy.
Oh my God.
The trophy is so detailed.
And those oh my God.
These heels.
I can kill a person with those heels.
I love how like this trophy.
The trophy is like it's very well illustrated for the trophy and just the composition in general of everything.
Like it's just it's just a really nice drawing overall and we're falling catches.
No, maybe it was me.
I'd be like goodbye.
But I love the composition.
I love how the backgrounds and I love how the pose in general the colors of the color selection and everything.
It's just very well drawn.
This one by seriously McGain.
I love the line art.
This is a different art style.
It's much more creative, but I love the background.
I love how they did.
The background because it's like it's just so I like I don't know.
What's the word?
It's like very I could see this as a t-shirt type deal, you know, like so like it's something you can see like maybe it's from like an animate like an animation or something.
Yeah, it's like pop art.
Yeah, it's very I love how it's very stylistic and it's just the background.
Just feel is just very pretty.
I think the background is just really pretty and I love how the line art the liner the differences in liner.
I believe I'm the moon here too.
I believe I believe this is the moon.
But I just very much enjoy the composition in this overall here.
We have Shady Cat.
I love the.
Use of screen tone for this.
The fact that like they played around with different types of screen tone different shapes to like the the what's the word these shapes of the brush of the screen tone and like just how like it's like colored.
It's so clean.
Yeah, I really like I just really like the shading and just this one that's Shady Cat.
All right, we're almost at the final stretch guys.
We have 12 more to go 12.
More 12 more and then we announce who wins.
We're very good 12 more to go.
I can't believe I showed almost a hundred hundred artwork.
This is shark e Tron.
I love how it includes everybody.
It's so dynamic.
Like it's just so cute.
Not enough dynamics.
Not the right word, but like I love how it has everybody that Chonky goon regular goon the bun buns.
Egg goon long goon tomato and then like the thief outfit and then the game yourself logo and it's just in my assets.
I didn't notice that I just I saw somebody was like, holy buff.
I was like, what do you mean?
I was like, wow, that was I guess like maybe now I can't unsee it.
And also that guys the eyes are up here.
I was focused on my wonderful personality.
Okay, let's focus on my wonderful personality.
I didn't notice that.
Anyway, here we have Shaycee.
I really like the background of everything like it's just very.
Well, come the screen tone chaining.
It's just this looks this can look like a really good t-shirt in general in terms of like the screen printing and stuff like a black and white shirt.
Like I just really like the style the shading that we use the screen tones for highlights and shading and it's very clean.
Yeah, I agree.
It's a very clean style.
It's very well balanced to and and then there's you there's you guys.
Hey, there's you guys who like haven't evolved very well because you still have your horns only the chonky goons are supposed to have their horns.
But like you have yours to this one is by Shin bun.
This is a really nice trophy that the details on that trophy alone.
Like whoa, like I love like details on the trophy and and the details in general.
You know, like the hair style the hair and then the trophy and like there's me as well right here.
And the way that like I'm like coming off on the side and like overflowing from the rectangular box as well.
Like the hair like I'm poking out of it and it's like I'm poking out of the box being like hey guys use my gamer subs code.
Did you guys know if you use my gamer sub code you get 10% off like?
So I really like that.
I just love how like I just love how people do hair really well is I don't know.
There's something about it.
Anyway, cheerleader.
There's a lot to say about this.
Sabi by this by Sabi one one, but also like the little this to be like cheer.
This why are you underneath me?
It's really cute.
I just find this I find this drawing incredibly cute, especially like the the pump the theming wise of it.
The theming wise the fact that like this part like they can have like like it has little parts of my outfit and it's just the theme itself.
It's just really cute and the box has like like little like what is it called?
Little bumps to symbolize like the pom-poms as well as sticking on the hair.
We own the hair.
Oh my God.
I love good line-up for hair, but it's a really pretty like composition and outfit in general.
It's just really cute.
This one is by Sonic blue speed.
So Sonic blue speed.
I'm holding a gamer subs within a game.
Word of.
I'm like, okay.
I don't know what's wrong with me here, but this is a gamer subs within a gamer subs the Chonky Mato.
This is like you left your tomato out in the sun for too long.
You left your tomato out in the sun.
But I love the way.
I love the way like the whole thing is composed as well.
I love this guy's expression.
I love it.
It's like he's just like he's just like hello.
You left me out in the sun for five hours.
It's a to me.
You left me out in the sun for five days.
Please.
Too much game.
No, there's no such no too little gamer subs.
Too little gamer subs.
You better use my code to feed this to fix this tomato.
Anyway, I love the composition.
I love like the idea.
I like how like it's holding a gamer subs within the gamer subs, which I thought was really cute.
And I just love like the way it's done.
The style is really cute in general.
And then we have Star Knights.
OMG.
The face when they draw the teeth like that.
The way sometimes when artists do that type of art with the mouth down mouth.
Yes.
There's some artists that draw like this for the mouths and it's like mwah like chef's kiss.
Like oh the yes the thing the way they shade the mouth like ah, it's just that was just the way.
They draw mouths.
It's like the teeth enjoys.
Yeah, I like the things and stuff.
Yeah, I just I just can't stop looking at the face.
It's just a really nice way of drawing the face, especially the mouth the shading on like you can see the backside of the backside of the jaw teeth to like right here and then the colors of the mouth and then the trophy is really well.
I really like the trophy design too.
Like it's like I won a race.
In general.
But yeah, this is love how they draw faces.
This one start with the same nose.
Okay, they both have star.
They both had stars.
So I got confused.
10 more.
More.
We're almost there.
Starlight Akari.
I love the shading.
It's just like I'm pretty sure this is a gradient too.
I love the shading and like it looks like I was like.
I won like a gladiator fight because this reminds me of like the Roman like Hercules.
Like it reminds me of Hercules and like the trophy but the shading is really well done and little sparkles to like like like I said the camera Sparkle.
See look now.
You're here.
Chonky goon.
Remember when the drawing to kicked you out, but now you're here.
You get your own you get your own drawing.
You get to be in the artwork now.
Haha.
Sarah Lee.
This was from Surah lead.
I look like I'm about to die the tomato but like I don't know.
I look like I'm about to murder somebody or I'm about to die the tomato in general, but this is really cute.
I love like how cute the I'm drawn here in general and then obviously like me me me me and bow bow are here as well with us and.
And then like I just love how the style is really cute.
The tomato is overstimulated.
I just signed a style like really adorable.
Yeah, it's just the face is really really cute.
Here is sweet and round.
I look like I just won football.
I just I want a football match and we're like.
Pour one out for the coach.
I like it.
It's so creative.
I find this.
I find like I won.
I won the sport, you know, like when you're playing the sport thing and then you win the sport and then look like the tomatoes cheering on in the background to here and then you you know, you pour.
I think this is American thing too.
I'm pretty sure I've only seen this happening in TV shows and movies.
So I don't know it like if this is an actual thing people do but I really.
I but it's it.
I thought this is a really cute composite like a cute idea.
Why is it when you mean it's great.
You mean it's it's not white.
That's great.
This is white.
This is gray.
It's Gatorade.
I like this because it looks like I have a tramp stamp on the butt.
Anyway, this is me Rooney.
This is umi Rooney.
The background itself is like super creative and the tomato here too.
Looks like I have a tramp stamp on my like you see the little bump here.
Do you guys see the little bump here?
Yeah, what about tomato has an ass but I just love the composition and this is a very creative way to draw the pose and everything and this one's great.
I love this.
I love the the the crack and the trap stamp.
All right.
This is a varia Ranto.
Um, I love like always like the little like anime like like you tell I'm laughing and everything and I do love the way this is drawn like though the style of this is such a smug expression.
Okay.
Yes in the thigh.
Oh, wow.
I think my thighs are bigger than my arm.
Accurate like
it looks like you're fucking crush a watermelon.
But I really love this like how smug I look for this one.
They are this is by varia Ranto.
Oh weirdo.
I love this style because it's like what a fucking brat.
What a fucking gremlin.
It's so smug.
It's so smug and um, it I just love I love the style because it feels like it fits my personality a lot.
It yeah, it captures my personality and it's like super sassy and like super like.
Like smug and everything the attitude for this.
I think was like is really well done the hair shading to as well as like it's just a very clean piece of art is very clean in general.
I just think this really this really like fits in my personality.
Yeah, we have one two three four five left guys five left before we decide the winner before I reveal the winner.
XNRZEW.
This is by this artist.
I love how I'm like gripping my oh my God.
You're the Dragoon is so cute here.
Wait the way the Dragoon is drawn is actually so cute and look you look like a Sanrio character.
You look like you look like a Sanrio character here.
Like yeah, it's so cute.
This yes.
This is say so dokey before the infection.
So I'm right here.
I'm like you see.
That girl.
Yeah, that's my girl.
It's very cute.
Yet the honest tomato in the background here.
So I really love the style and I love the Dragoon.
You look like such a Sanrio character.
I'm drowning.
This is by you.
I'm just like drowning in caper stuff.
That's all I can describe it.
I thought that was I thought I was really funny away later.
You got to drink all your caper supper.
I'll drown.
I thought the I thought the idea was incredibly creative.
That's chatting of my comfort.
Great.
Don't drink the substance.
Save her.
I thought.
I thought the idea was incredibly creative.
Yeah, drink faster.
You had to chug it.
But the concept was really well done.
Here is the pocket droid.
I love okay.
You guys don't notice this.
The background is like money silhouettes of the money and I love the use of line art.
Wait on this.
Like it's so.
Bold like is that the right word?
Like it's the the line art is very bold and yeah, it's very cool to look at the liner in general because it's like the weight of the line art is is very in like not what's the word is very crisp and like interesting to look at.
Yeah, because there's like the thickness of the lines here.
But then they play around with the weight of the line.
And then there's like little shading with line art to like the way they'd line art.
This is just very dying.
Like it's just a really nice style.
I really enjoyed the sound and I like the how the background is like the silhouettes of money in the background, which I thought was really interesting last to this one is by Zara.
Neon 17.
So I like the checkered background.
It really balances the whole piece.
So but I really it's just a really cute art style.
And yeah, the face like I love the face.
I'm like wait.
Yeah, that's what I look like and then squishing the chunk moon.
I think the face is like really cutely drawn and then I love how the little chunky coolness like in between my arms.
And I'm just like hugging you guys.
And the gamers of logo is like the clip on the you know, how like it's like one of the one of the the symbols from the car playing cars.
And then they use the gamer sub gamer sub logo for for it.
Eyes are up here.
This is by Julio.
Okay guys remember eyes are up here.
Hahaha.
But it's a very... well, it's very well drawn.
And like the pose itself, like it's a very confident pose.
That's for sure.
It's a very... It's a very confident pose.
And then, oh my god, I love how I'm holding a gun.
And I'm like, yeah, what are you looking at, buddy?
But yes, as you all know, there are other parts of this drawing that's also very well illustrated.
But I shall focus on the eyes right now.
I shall focus on the eyes.
And so... and then the rest is these two.
Do you guys see the other two?
Alright.
Alright, so...
I would like drum roll, please.
Should I go?
Okay, I will do honorable mentions.
I will start from the bottom for honorable mentions.
And then we'll go... we'll go up from there.
So...
Drum roll!
Drum roll, please!
We're finally here.
It only took us two hours to get through 100 plus entries.
Now imagine my assistant trying to get through 700 entries to narrow it down to 100.
And then I had to narrow it down to 34.
So like a round of applause for my assistant for getting through 700 entries.
To narrow it down to 100.
And then I had to narrow it down to 34.
So honorable mentions...
They... unfortunately...
There's no like prize money for honorable mention.
But I still wanted to like give you guys like, you know, a mention.
When I picked... like I said, when I picked these artwork...
I picked... I chose versus personality.
I... like... how... does it fit?
Does it fit my personality for the top 20... top 22?
And like with honorable mentions.
I looked at like, does it fit my personality?
Is it... is it like something that I think would look really good on a cup?
Do I... I wanted to have different styles represented in the top 22.
And... well, the top 20 plus honorable mentions.
I wanted the composition created like the creativity and the... the creativity.
And how it's... how like they took the idea to make the artwork.
Um... stuff like that.
I know some people might be like, oh, that's not in my...
This is... I got... I did the final judgment, guys.
In the end, I did the final judgment for everything.
Um... so like maybe some of your favorite pieces aren't in the honorable mentions.
Or... um... or... uh... or like the top 22.
It was very difficult.
It was so difficult.
I also wanted to give attention to like...
I feel like artists that like different types of art styles as well.
Um... I wanted to have like different types of art styles and everything.
So... um... it was... it was def... it was so hard to pick.
I...
It was... it was honestly one of the hardest decisions I had to make for this.
Anyway, we'll start with honorable mentions.
Our first honorable mention from...
Clero Art.
Um...
I won't be describing too much of the...
Artwork pieces regarding...
Um... I think I'll start describing them more when we're at the top five.
But this is our first honorable mention.
Congratulations to Clero Art.
Uh... for... for getting to the top 34.
Um... so... congratulations.
The honorable mentions are not ranked, by the way.
It's just how... wherever I place them.
They're not... It's not like this is the 34th piece.
Um... it's...
They're not placed anywhere.
Um, similar with 6th to 20th.
They don't have like a placement for them.
It's only, they're all grouped up together in 6th to 20th.
So, Claro Art is the first honorable mention.
Um...
Sweet and Round...
Um, is the next honorable mention.
Um, I just really love the idea.
Like, I thought the idea was very creative.
And that's why I chose this one for the honorable mention.
The reason why I chose Claro Art for the honorable mention was because I just love the art style and the composition.
The slantedness of it.
I thought the slantedness of it was really nicely done.
Uh, very creative.
I think I gave Claro Art two honorable mentions because I loved both of their submissions.
So, I just thought it was very creative in a way.
Um, that they done it.
So, that's why they had two honorable mentions.
Um, Matt also got an honorable mention.
Uh, I love the style.
Um, I love the style of it.
And the creativity regarding like...
Um, it looks like a comic panel.
Um...
And I just love how creative it was.
And like the direction they took with...
Uh, with the piece for the artwork.
Um...
This one...
Uh, another honorable mention would be Lemmy.
Um, I really liked the...
I just love the details and everything.
And the little dragoon pom-poms that everybody is in there included.
And the little dragoon pom-poms.
And just the little details.
Like you can see how much like the blush had screen tone and everything.
Um, so I just love the little details.
Um, another honorable mention is Frel.
Um, I love how dynamic the...
Like the background.
I just love the way...
The composition, the background, the pose.
And just how clean everything is.
So, that's why Frel is also an honorable mention.
Um, Hito also got an...
Whoa, you saw the other honorable mention.
But...
Um, Hito also got an honorable mention.
Um, it was a very cute art drawing.
And like...
I wanted every outfit to be represented.
I wanted every outfit to have a representation in the...
Uh...
In the top 34.
So, I had to pick...
I wanted to like have one of each outfit in the top 34.
So, I really liked Hito's rendition of this outfit.
I thought it was really cute.
And the fact that it looked like an emblem, per se.
Um, and like the symmetry of everything too.
So, Hito got an honorable mention.
Um, Screetuber, I already talked about it.
There's just something about the style that's just very captivating.
Um, and that's why...
Um, that's why I picked Screetuber as an honorable mention.
The style was just very...
Very captivating and very unique compared to the rest of the drawing.
Uh...
And finally, the last honorable mention is...
Taihen Gold.
Um...
Well, I just really love gamer subs.
Like...
I just...
I really love gamer subs.
That's...
That's really it.
Like, oh my god.
Gamer subs.
By the way, you can use 10%...
Use my gamer sub code, Doughkeeper, for 10% off.
Alright!
6th to 20th place.
I shall now showcase 6th to 20th place.
So...
Um...
The first winner...
Not winner, sorry.
The first person who placed...
Um...
Who placed in...
Uh...
Placed is 7M Digital.
I just...
I could see this as like a graphic t-shirt.
Like, I thought it was really...
The perspective and the...
Um...
Composition...
Is like...
I just thought it was like really interesting to look at.
And like, I love the way...
Like, the line art and the shading of everything was done.
So like, the background forces you to look at her.
Like, me.
Sorry.
Me.
Number one.
And so...
Um...
I really liked how the background forces your eyes to look at me here.
And I just love the...
How clean everything is too.
And the composition in general and the perspective.
Um...
And that's why 7M Digital made it to the final pick.
The finals.
Um...
Next up...
Is...
Uh...
Mala Leafy Daisy.
I love the background and the details.
I think like...
The background...
The void goons...
I just love this idea.
And that's why I placed it into my final judgement.
Because...
The dragoon background was very interesting and a very creative take.
Uh...
Compared to like a lot of the other entries.
I think the background was what...
Like...
Hooked me in the most.
Um...
The rest of the pieces also very well done.
And like...
Um...
The eyes are like really pretty.
The line work in general.
And everything.
And...
But like the background was what sold me the most.
I just felt like it was incredibly creative.
Obviously a lot of work as well.
And like how like they comp...
Like made the composition of this.
Was...
Um...
Very creative.
The next one.
Similar to...
Um...
The other piece.
Seriously.
I talked about it a lot.
I loved the way this was composed.
I...
Just something about it.
The look...
Like the pop art for it.
The stylistic choice of it.
Was just...
Very...
Interesting.
In general.
Like very creative.
And I just...
The line work.
Of how they did the sit...
The background...
Like...
Um...
Elements of everything.
Like the moon.
The stars.
The...
The apartments.
Um...
Just really well done.
And that's why they also...
Uh...
Placed 6th to 20th.
Um...
Next one.
Uh...
Guy Keary.
I like the trophy.
The tomato and the trophy.
And I picked this because...
The perspective too.
Was really well done.
Cause your eyes are drawn to this at first.
And I thought it was just really well done.
In terms of like...
How...
They did the perspective of everything.
And how your eyes are drawn to tomato.
And you're like...
Wow!
Haha!
That's cute!
That's so cute!
And then you're like...
Wow!
Um...
And that's why...
They also placed 6th to 20th.
Um...
For this one...
I love the face.
From DokuroDX.
The face is just...
There's just something about...
The way this is drawn.
The face too.
Like...
It's just...
I know like...
Um...
I wanna say like...
Uh...
Dokuro...
DokuroDX...
Was...
Um...
Cause I had staff...
Give input and everything.
And...
One of the staff members...
Really loved...
How...
The way...
The head...
Was drawn.
And they actually put this in their top 5.
Um...
Because of like...
They were like...
They like...
Loved this part.
Of the drawing.
Like the head.
Um...
It was so difficult guys.
Like...
It was so difficult to...
Haha!
To...
Um...
To like...
Figure this out.
Um...
But yeah...
I...
And then the...
The ghost of the dead dragoons...
By my side...
Um...
And then we have...
Rosen...
We all know why this one was...
Got made into...
Hahaha!
I feel like I don't need to explain why.
Like...
Hahaha!
I don't need it.
I don't really need to explain why.
But everything is...
about it.
The reason why...
Um...
For me...
It wasn't placed higher...
Was...
Because I also looked into...
Like...
Uh...
The reason why...
The reason why for me...
It wasn't placed higher...
Was...
Because I was like...
Hahaha!
I was like...
I don't know...
Hahaha!
Haha!
But it's a very good piece.
It's really well done.
The detail is amazing in general.
Alright, the next one we have...
I love the concept.
I love the maid outfit.
I love the fact that it was...
It's like my outfit turned into a maid outfit.
And all the dragoons are here as well.
I just love the creativity.
This is my burnt green tea.
Sorry.
Ignore the honorable mention.
Yeah, sorry.
I forgot to delete this.
It's not honorable mention, by the way.
I forgot to delete this part.
It's not honorable mention.
This guy...
This guy placed...
This guy... I know it's like...
Can I delete it?
No, I can't.
I can only view only.
Ignore the honorable mention.
It's actually...
It's actually won a prize.
I swapped things around.
It's not honorable mention.
It actually won.
It actually got 6th to 20th.
I just forgot to delete that part.
But yes, the reason I picked this...
I just love the outfit contest in general.
But yeah, this is why I picked it as...
Not honorable mention, but it got placed.
The reason why I got confused is that...
Yes, this isn't honorable mention.
It's because they had two pieces of our...
I really liked both their entries.
And I had to pick one.
And I picked out of these two...
I picked this one to be placed.
I love the face.
There's just something about the way the face is drawn...
That was very appealing to me.
And then you guys have your Naruto headband too.
And I just love the way the face and the head was drawn in general.
And that's why this one got placed.
And I had to choose between these two.
The reason why was that...
This is honorable mention.
I accidentally put two of her piece artwork into prize in 6th to 20th.
So I had to remove...
I had to like...
Oh, that's an oversight.
So that's why...
This used to be an honorable mention.
I moved her burnt green tea up into placements.
And put this in an honorable mention.
Because I got confused.
Anyway, next up is...
Oh my god, they're so...
Oh my god, it's gonna be...
I know, all of them are just really pretty.
It's S2 Nani07262.
This one also placed.
I love the composition.
I love like...
The background of it is so creative.
With the...
I assume this is like GamerSub Liquid.
With like...
Shaped like the dragoons and the tomato.
It's just very pretty.
It looks like a manga panel as well.
It...
Yeah, it looks like a manga panel.
And...
It just looks amazing in general.
Next one is...
KG Hazard.
Dartstyle.
Really sold me on this.
The fact that it was like...
A very unique art style.
Compared to like...
The other artwork.
So...
It was...
Very difficult.
It was very difficult to...
Oh my gosh, like I said, it was very difficult to pick.
But the art style really made it popped out a lot more.
And I really love...
It's just so creative.
I just love this art style.
Like it just brings me back to like...
The retro days.
For Retro Doki.
When do we...
When is it...
I need to count.
Are we at...
Okay.
I need to make sure like...
When we're...
Okay, let's see.
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Okay, we're almost there.
Okay, I was counting.
Defeating...
Yeah, guys.
Four...
And now one.
Yeah.
I think there was about...
That was all about this sort of Morro-j repairs...
And now about this...
But it goes into the next question.
Any other questions?
And...
De says, Okay, so...
We do encourage religious continuous appeasing, there's something you want.
If you are a BLM fan.
And the composition with the background.
I love the attitude.
And that's why this one was also picked into it.
It was just... it just looks like I'm the fucking boss.
It looks like I'm the fucking boss lady.
So it got there.
Another one.
I love the creativity.
As if I was on a playing card.
I liked how it looked like I was on a playing card.
And the way it's drawn and everything, the style-wise.
And how I'm getting out of the box too.
And that's why I picked this for the placements.
I'm going fast for this because I already explained why I really like each artwork individually.
So I'm just explaining why I picked it in general.
I'm explaining why I picked it.
You can tell that I picked a lot of different styles going in.
Because I really want to diversify...
Yeah, it looks like a tarot card.
I want to diversify the styles.
So each different style has its own placement in here.
And then the background was what sold me for this.
It was just so creative.
I love the background of how this was drawn.
I love how clean this is.
And that's why I picked it up here.
Because the background was just so fucking clean.
It's just so creative.
Like the star at the end.
Oh my god.
I was just wow.
I think this is the last...
6th...
The 20th thing.
So the Seppa Kanken.
The composition.
The pose.
The way the trophy was drawn.
And the stars too.
And that's why I picked this one.
For the finalists.
So it's just...
Everything about it was just really well done.
And finally, we are at...
I think 5th place.
4th to 5th.
When I saw this on Twitter...
I loved this drawing.
When I saw...
I remember when I saw this on Twitter.
I actually...
I love this drawing.
I just love the idea of it too.
So this is now...
We're at top 5.
We are at top 5.
So I was...
I really liked how fun it is.
Like how creative this is.
And how fun the drawing is.
And it just felt like it fit my personality.
So that is why I picked this in the top 5.
This artist had like...
2 artworks that were really good.
And so it was very hard to pick.
Because...
Well they had 3 entries.
And it was really hard to pick one of them.
So...
This is by GrimSilvers.
The details.
The details is beautiful.
I love the shading.
The details.
The choice of what to make that's transparent.
And...
And that's why I picked this drawing.
The other artwork they did was for the other guys who are very enthusiastic.
This is an honorable mention.
Because their other artwork was also really good.
The details of everything was also really good.
So...
But yes.
This GrimSilvers got 4th to 5th.
I'm trying to remember what the prize money was again.
I know I said it.
So for those who don't know.
4th to 5th gets $250.
6th to 20th gets $100.
3rd gets $500.
2nd gets $1000.
And the 2 winners get $2500 each.
So just a reminder for everybody.
And I believe...
2nd to 5th will be made into a sticker pack.
So...
This and this will be stickers.
If you buy the bundle, you'll get stickers with these designs.
Anyway.
3rd.
3rd is...
I picked Fluffy Catfish.
I thought the idea was so creative.
It looks like I'm on a drink brand.
You know?
Like a drink advertisement.
It looked like I was on these classy drink advertisements.
And I thought that this idea was so creative.
And the little dokey bird at the end there.
At the bottom.
And I just realized that...
This is like...
You know like a classy margarita type deal.
Like a cocktail.
It looks like I'm on a cocktail drink advertisement at a club.
Like a fancy club.
Like those...
Like the 1940's clubs and stuff.
So I thought this was very creative in the way it was done.
Like a dokey teeny.
Yeah!
And that's why I picked it as 3rd place.
Alright.
Now we're on to the two 2nd placements.
Seishi is our first 2nd place winner.
I just thought overall everything was very well done.
I really liked the entire composition in general.
And I love just how everything was drawn.
Like the background, the pose, the shading.
It's so clean.
It was very clean and very like...
It just worked really well in general.
Like everything coming together.
And that's why...
This is our first 2nd place winner.
And then our other 2nd place winner was...
Wiro.
My personality was showing so well in this drawing.
I thought it reflected the personality very very well.
And the fact that it was able to portray...
I just thought it did so well in terms of just portraying who I am.
Who I am.
What I put out as a brand.
And that is why I picked this one as the 2nd place winner.
So...
It was very difficult to pick one 1st place winner.
And GamerSupps was...
Oh, by the way.
I just realized it's not even $8000.
It's more than that.
It's a little bit more than that.
Because...
I just realized the math ain't right.
It's actually more than $8000.
I think it's like...
Because I ended up...
I think it's $8500.
I think.
Because I ended up picking 2...
2 1st place winners.
Instead of 3 2nd place winners.
Because originally it was going to be 3 2nd place winners.
Instead of...
Instead of 2 2nd place winners.
So...
I ended up picking...
2 1st place winners.
And GamerSupps is paying for all this prize money, by the way.
They are paying for all of the prize money.
And...
Sorry, $9500.
Okay, I'll edit.
Okay, guys.
I'll edit that right now.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, fine.
I'll edit that right now.
Damn!
And...
So, I asked them if it was possible.
And they were like...
They were like...
Yes.
Yeah, we can do that.
We can have...
We can pay off...
We can give...
We can have 2 first place winners.
Because it was very difficult.
Picking the last 2.
So, the first one I'm gonna show that got first place, they actually had, they submitted multiple entries, so it was very difficult because I really like both of their entries.
So, I'll show their honorable mention, so you might remember, you might remember their artwork.
So, their honorable mention, which I had to pick between the two.
Drumroll please.
This is an honorable mention, this is by the same artist.
It was very difficult picking between the one that did win, versus this one, because I loved the stickers, I felt like it looked so good on the cup.
Because like, it's not printed that big in general, so I felt like the face was very well done.
And I felt like it really, like it has like, you know, it has Alt Doki and Alternative Doki, which a lot of people love Alternative Doki.
And the trophy wise with the little stickers on there.
But, so the one I did pick, the one I did pick was, if you guys don't remember who it was, like their other artwork, was this one.
So, the reason why I picked this one was...
Okay, the one thing, I love that it says Doki Bird.
Some people were like, who's this waifu cup?
And then they'll be like, oh it's Doki Bird.
But it's not just that, it's not just that.
Anyway, I love, like I love the concept, like it's just, I felt like this fits a lot of like, the personality.
It's not because of the, it was, I'm joking guys, it's not because of the text.
Like...
I'm joking.
It's not because of the text, the reason why I picked this.
I'm joking guys.
I thought this drawing in general, I thought...
It's not because of name dropping.
It's also because I thought it fit my personality really well.
It's very clean, like it's very clean.
Um...
I love the way they did the background.
You can see like the smoke coming out behind me if you look closer.
And the trophy, with the GamerSup logo on the trophy.
And then like the little sparkle.
And then there's also like...
Um...
The fact that the tomato's face...
Like...
The tomato face there is...
I love...
But I felt like overall...
The overallness of everything...
It was just like...
It was just very Doki Bird.
Um...
It was incredibly Doki Bird.
And like branding-wise, personality, it just really fit me and everything.
Um...
And that's why like I picked this as one of the first place winners.
Now...
The other first place winner...
Alright, drumroll please.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba...
Drumroll!
The other first place winner...
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba...
Is...
Meiju...
Uh...
J-U-W...
I'm so sorry.
Meiju...
I think.
I...
It's beaut...
It's a beautiful artwork.
Like...
Um...
Really like...
I think like this is incredibly well drawn.
It's very beautiful.
Um...
I thought like it's also a different style.
It's a different style from the other side.
So...
What is gonna happen is that the waifu cup...
The front and the back will be different.
So one side will be the other drawing and the other side will be this one.
So...
That is what...
So you can have the best of both worlds.
Um...
So it's gonna be on the same cup together.
And I like that it's also like a different style too.
It's very like different style.
It's beautifully drawn and everything.
And like...
You know...
There's like...
There's me also here.
I love the little bites.
Also like...
The little bites really help.
Just like...
The tiny ass fucking face.
You know I have that?
Wait...
I actually...
I never showed you guys this.
Like...
Give me a sec.
I actually realized I never showed you guys.
Oh my god.
I never showed you guys...
What I can do.
Give me a sec.
Um...
Let me see.
Where is it?
I haven't...
We haven't...
Um...
We haven't done this in a while.
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Oh no.
Which one is it?
What was the...
What was the trigger?
I don't...
I don't remember.
No.
I'm trying to remember how to...
I'm sorry, give me a sec.
I know I'm sorry.
I need to show you this.
It's so important.
It's actually so important, but I don't... I will remember.
Guys, I will remember this.
It's very... oh my god.
Where is it?
There's no way.
Did I?
Guys, I think I accidentally deleted it.
No!
It was so funny!
I must have accidentally deleted it!
I'm so sad!
Wait, no.
Wait, let me see if I can find it.
Guys, let me see if I can find it.
Is it this?
Is it this one?
Guys, give me a sec.
I know you guys are like, what's going on?
No!
I don't know what it was called.
You don't understand.
I actually don't remember what it was called.
Guys, guys, no.
I swear it's gonna be so worth it when I find it.
Guys, I swear to god.
Guys, it's gonna be so worth it the moment I find this.
It's so worth it.
I just need to figure out... oh, is it this?
Wait, I think it is.
It's okay.
Okay.
I found it.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Do you realize I never showed you guys this?
Okay.
Okay, wait, give me a sec.
I should not...
be there.
Okay.
Okay, guys, guys, guys.
Guys.
Oh, guys.
Okay, this is very important.
Watch this.
Watch this, guys.
I forgot to show... I realized I never showed you guys this one.
Hey, guys.
I was not being porn dead.
Oh my god.
That's not me.
That was so funny to watch.
That's what reminded me of.
Think this is somebody's ears.
I wasn't.
So yeah.
That's why I also, I really liked that like it's real.
Come on man.
Like it's real.
I love the tomato and the artwork was like the faces like this.
I was so funny.
I told you.
I told you it was worth it!
I told you!
I told you it was so worth it, guys!
You must be like, please, Doki, anytime.
I told you it was so worth it!
The way it was worth it, chat, is...
Yeah, I can turn it off, see?
Anyway, let me go back into my skin, see?
I gotta pilot my mech real fast.
Let me...
Let me get back in.
Let me get back into the mech.
Anyway...
So yeah, that's what I wanted to show you guys.
That's what I wanted to show you guys.
But yes, these are...
These are the...
Winners.
The first... The first place winners, these two.
I figured they both will look amazing on the waifu cup.
But now, for those who are wondering...
When will we get the waifu cup?
Pre-orders, I believe.
This is a rough estimate, by the way, guys.
This is a rough estimate.
But...
We are looking at November.
For the pre-orders.
Pre-orders will include...
In November will be when we're...
Pre-orders will be ready.
And it will include...
The waifu cup.
The waifu cup t-shirts designs.
You can get these designs as t-shirts, basically.
So, like, individual.
So they will be as t-shirts.
And also, I believe, second to fifth place winners will be a sticker bundle.
If you buy the bundle...
If you buy the whole bundle...
You will get them...
You will be receiving stickers of the second to fifth place winners.
So, yeah!
That's basically all the details regarding...
Um...
Regarding...
The...
The gamer sub stuff.
The waifu cup.
Wow!
It took a very long time to judge this.
I'm so happy this is finally...
I don't have to deal with judging...
Do...
Like, doing more judging anymore.
It was so difficult!
It was...
It was so difficult to judge!
I'm so happy!
Like, we finally figured it out!
Hahaha!
And I hope you guys...
Um...
I hope you guys...
Like the artworks I picked...
Um...
For the waifu cup and the finalists too.
I hope you guys...
You guys agree with me regarding the finalists.
It was so difficult.
I'm sorry you didn't make it to the...
As the finalists.
I just want you guys to know, like...
It was very, very, very difficult.
It took me five months to reach this...
This decision.
Hahaha!
It took me so long!
Um...
But let's congratulate all the winners.
Let's congratulate all the winners.
And all the participants.
All 700 plus participants who entered the contest.
If I could, I would pick more.
Um...
But congratulations to everybody for all your hard work.
For...
Um...
For, like, entering the art contest.
You guys are very talented.
And I hope the other dragoons enjoyed watching the stream.
And seeing all the winners.
Like, seeing all the artwork.
Seeing the people that entered.
Um...
And everything.
And if you guys want to see more of the artwork, please just look up on Twitter.
The waifu cup art contest.
Uh...
Twitter...
Hashtag...
What is even...
What is my hashtag again?
Um...
Hahaha!
The doki waifu cup contest!
If you look at the hashtag, the doki waifu cup contest, you'll be able to see all the other entries who might not have made the...
The cut to the top.
115.
It was very difficult to narrow it down to 115 from my assistant.
So please check out the hashtag to look at more of the artwork if you guys are curious on who...
Um...
Who...
Uh...
Who else entered.
But yes!
Congratulations!
Yeah!
It's over!
Hahaha!
Yippee!
Now it's like...
Now we wait on November!
Now we wait November!
Hahaha!
To see...
To...
For the pre-orders to come out!
I'm so tired.
Hahaha!
I'm tired now.
I'm going to go to my other chat room.
Hahaha!
Now...
Now it's relax time!
The competition part is over now.
Hahaha!
Now it's relaxation time!
Oh my god!
I'm just happy to...
Now I can rest for now.
Yeah!
Um...
I hope you guys enjoyed watching today's stream.
It's a little different from what I usually stream, but like I said, I was just showcasing um...
All the people.
Because they, you know, they put so much time...
They put so much time...
Um...
With their...
With...
With their artwork and entering the contest and like putting their skills out there in front of everybody.
I hope you guys discovered so many amazing artists.
Um...
All the artists that entered and support all the artists, even those that didn't make it to the finals.
Uh...
You guys Folge them, check them out.
They're all so fucking talented.
So I'm like really happy to be able to like have so many talented individuals like enter this contest.
And I was able to showcase as much as I could and give my comments on all of them and everything.
And...
Yeah!
Yeah, it was... it was a lot of talking.
Definitely next week I'm going to talk a lot less.
As in like, I'm going to do... I'm going to like... have like a curfew when it comes to my streams for next week.
Because I need to rest my voice.
My voice is slowly dying today.
My slow voice is slowly dying, so I definitely need to rest my vocal cords for next week.
What do I want to say?
But yeah, I am... I am...
Well, it's just nice to have another thing done, you know, off the to-do list.
Obviously, I have so much stuff on my to-do list.
But it's nice that... that it's nice that... to have another thing being like, Check!
I did it!
I made progress in life!
Another thing to check off the list that I owe... that I had to do!
Yeah, one less thing in the backlog.
I'm so happy to finally be able to announce the winners.
And like... and being able to like, progress in life in terms of like, my to-do list and everything.
And being able to showcase so many wonderful, talented artists and individuals today.
Yeah, it's been... it's definitely worth it.
I'm so happy.
To showcase.
I love art.
I love being able to showcase all like, such talented people.
So it was such a joy to do.
Let's see.
Black, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you for making time to show the final pics.
Feels like everyone won!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I really... I really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Oh my god, I'm so tired.
I'm looking forward to seeing... seeing how it looks like though.
When it... when the samples come in.
I'm super excited to see what the samples will look like.
And how... just to have... like, be able to see it IRL.
You know, and see the... like, what it looks like printed on the cup.
And the t-shirts too.
And I get to get it for free.
Because it's my brand.
I love free stuff.
I love...
Yay!
Free t-shirt!
I don't need to buy clothes!
Yay!
I would never wear it in public.
I feel...
If anything...
If I wear that shit in public...
They'll be like...
Hmm...
Why do you sound like her?
And why...
It's gonna be pajamas.
Yay!
Free pajamas!
It'll be...
Let's go!
Oh yeah, story time.
It's about dad again.
It's always about him.
He always fucking does a new thing.
This isn't a story I told in members.
But it's a different story.
Because something new happened yesterday.
I took him for a walk yesterday.
We bumped into this lady with two dogs.
And he wouldn't leave her alone.
What do you mean by he wouldn't leave her alone?
He was in love with her.
Just because she pet...
She petted him.
And you know what was so fucked?
She was like...
Wouldn't it be funny if I took the leash...
If I took the leash and just walked away with him?
Do you think he'll follow me?
And I'll be like...
And she's like...
Can I try?
So then I gave her the leash.
And then...
And then dad just ran off with her.
Like...
To the...
To a different direction that was not towards home.
And then I was like...
What the fuck?
Bro, he ain't loyal.
Bro!
He literally walked in a different direction.
That was not my usual...
Our usual path by the way.
And like...
Like with her.
And then she like brought him back.
It was like...
Oh, wait.
He...
He was just like...
Oh my god.
He really just loves me.
And I'm just like...
Yeah.
Tears.
And then I was like...
Alright, dad.
Come on.
We gotta go.
We gotta go home now.
We have to head home.
And then...
He started crying.
He like...
He was like...
Like...
At the..
At the other lady.
He's like...
No...
So...
like he wouldn't move.
He was just looking at...
He was like...
But I want to go with her.
I was like...
You just met her!
He started whimpering and everything.
And then...
And then like...
And then I was like...
I gave you everything...
I gave you...
And then the lady was like...
Oh, I'll walk with you.
Um...
You already...
And then the moment she walked with me, he followed, like, he went right, he walked home.
The moment, the moment he fucking walked with, she walked with me, he was like, yay!
Yay!
And then we got to the door of my apartment, like, the door of the lobby of my apartment building.
And she's like, I gotta go now, miss you.
Bye-bye!
And then, and then he, like, looked at us, like, I'm like, what?
And then I was like, I was like, come on!
And I, like, pulled him.
And then, and then the moment, like, the door opened, he was like, okay.
And then he walked in!
He, like, it's the moment the door opened!
He's like, alright!
And he forgot about her.
And he's like, home time!
Yay!
Time to go home!
And then he just walks ahead of me, and I was like, yay!
I was just, I don't know, I even, I don't know what's wrong with everything!
I don't, just because this lady just started petting him, he was like, yay!
I'm gonna go home with her!
Yay!
I even bought him a new bed yesterday!
I was like, here's a more comfy bed for you, cause I love you!
And this bitch tried to fucking rock, run away with the other lady, I can't believe it!
I can't, I can't believe he tried to, or he actually was like, I gave the leash to the lady and he actually walked away from me!
Like, he's, he's, yes, he's using it!
He's literally sleeping in it right now!
Like, did you pet him?
Yes, I'm always petting him!
Oh my god!
Like, I don't understand!
I love him though, even though he breaks my heart like that!
Like, he just likes new smells!
I think he also smelled the treats on her!
The lady was like, oh yeah, like, I had lots of treats on me, but like, I don't have any right now!
Cause like, she has two dogs, she was like, walking two dogs, and she's like, oh, you must smell the treats on me!
I'm sorry, I don't have treats right now!
Maybe next time!
Like, she was like, saying that to my dog, maybe next time!
So I think he, like, smelled, like, treats, like, food on her, and he got, like, extra excited too, and was like, I'm going with her, she has more food!
And I'm like, I'm like, bro, okay, like, there was another...
pet owner next to us, and she was like, wow, your dog is so muscular.
And I was like, he is?
Like, they're like, wow, your dog is so muscular!
And I'm like, what?
I don't notice that!
I was like, really?
Yeah, my, apparently, apparently, dad's muscular!
I don't even notice!
I don't...
And then...
He's very food-motivated, by the way.
He's very food-motivated.
I'm pretty sure it's because he smelled treats on her.
He was like, she has treats and you don't give me treats sometimes.
I'm like, I don't want to overfeed you.
You're just a wiener dog.
You're long, but you're short.
A fat wiener dog is bad for the back.
I don't want to overfeed you.
Like, I don't want to fuck up your back.
It's not good for you to have more meat on you.
Maybe you paid attention to his games.
There'd be less MTR.
Mercy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, feed me, mother.
I feed you.
I feed him, like, so much.
But not too much.
Not too much that he's, like, overweight.
I feed him at a right amount.
I feed him a right amount of food.
But yeah, that's my dad.
The fact that he almost actually ran off with her.
Like, no hesitation, too.
The moment I gave the leash to the lady, he was ready.
He was so fucking ready.
He was so fucking...
He was waiting for this moment.
I need that protein, baby.
Okay.
But yeah, that's my...
That is my...
That's my dad's story of the day.
That is my dad's story of the day, guys.
But anyway, I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
I'm tired.
But as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
Subtitles by the Amara.org community